TALKING TO AN EMPTY HOUSE HERE
WEEKLY WE NORMALLY HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE PRESENT AN ALMOST EMPTY
HOUSE SUPPORT HIM AT. GOOD I'M
GLAD YOU'RE CALLING ME ON STUFF
ALREADY GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
AND WELCOME TO. A BUDGET
COMMITTEE SUB THREE YOU MAY.
HAVE NOTICED. THAT THE NAME OF
THE COMMITTEE IS SUDDENLY
GOTTEN A LITTLE BIT LONGER WE
ARE NOW. THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
CLIMATE CRISIS RESOURCES ENERGY
AND TRANSPORTATION AND THAT
CHANGE WAS MADE AT MY REQUEST-
BECAUSE I THOUGHT- OF A FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
OTHERS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE BREADTH OF THE
ISSUES. THAT WE DEAL WITH HERE
AT SEVEN THREE BUT THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS. IF WE REALLY PUT
DOWN ON PAPER ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT SUBJECT AREAS- OF THE
THAT WE COVER THERE WOULDN'T BE
ENOUGH ROOM ON A SINGLE SHEET
OF PAPER NOR MULTIPLICATIVE
SHEETS OF PAPER WE ACTUALLY
OVERSEE. THE WORK. OF OVER A
HUNDRED DEPARTMENTS- IN THE- IN
IN STATE GOVERNMENT. A OF ALL
THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE A PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION A THIRD OF THEM
ARE ARE COVERED IN BUDGET SUB
THREE- IF WE REALLY WANTED TO
COMMUNICATE EVEN IN EVEN MORE
DETAIL. WE WOULD TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT- THIS BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE ARE OVERSEAS
VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE RESPONSE
BEFORE DURING AND AFTER
WILDFIRES VOTE YOU KNOW THE- OF
PREVENTION. OF FIGHTING ACTUAL
FIRES AND THEN THE CLEAN UP
AFTERWARDS AND ALL THE EFFORTS
OF TAKE PLACE AFTER WILDFIRES
AND THAT'S REALLY NOT REFLECTED
IN THE IN THE CURRENT TITLE BUT
THAT'S THE REASON FOR THE
CHANGE AND- WERE ONLY MISSING
ONE MEMBER BUT I WANT TO-
BEGIN. BY WELCOMING. THREE NEW
MEMBERS TO OUR SUBCOMMITTEE WE
HAVE- OF MS FRIEDMAN- AND-
MISTER SMITH AND MISTER BENNETT
WHO ARE GRACING THE DIETS AND
ALL WITH US THIS MORNING
WELCOME TO BUDGET SUB THREE-
AS- I SAID WE COVER A LOT OF
GROUND HERE AND I KNOW- HAVING
SPOKEN TO OFF ALL OF YOU AND
KNOWING HIS FRIEDMAN FOR MANY
YEARS NOW- THAT THESE ARE.
ISSUES OF INTEREST TO YOU AND
THAT YOU'LL BE OF PLAYING A
PRODUCTIVE ROLE IN MOVING THE-
OF THE BUDGET FORWARD AND
HAVING THEIR INPUT ON- THE
PANOPLY OF ISSUES THAT THAT WE
ADDRESS WE HAVE- OUR ****
BECOME. ROUTINE IN AND
COMMITTEES A NUMBER OF. GROUND
RULES- AND DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION- THAT WE
ANNOUNCED AT THE BEGINNING OF
EVERY MEETING. AND SO LET ME-
BEGIN BY TELLING YOU THAT TODAY
WE'RE HAVING A- UP IT WASN'T
HOT HITS THE PHYSICALLY DISTANT
IN PERSON HEARING IN THE STATE
CAPITAL WERE ROOM FOR THIRTY
SEVEN. IN ORDER TO KEEP SIX
FEET OF SPACE AIN'T GONNA
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE- A FEW MEMBERS-
WE'RE FORTUNATE THAT WE ARE.
JUST THE RIGHT SIZE TO FIT ALL
OF THE OTHER MEMBERS ON THE
DYESS. WE HAVE A MINIMAL
CONTENTION ASAPH AND A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE- VERY SPARSE
ATTENDANCE HERE THIS MORNING IN
THE GALLERY. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. NOW RESTATE
THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT BEGINS
BUT IF ANY ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISHES TO SPEAK ON
PUBLIC COMMENT- IF YOU'RE HERE.
IN THE BUILDING ARE IN THE
ROOM- THEN- I WILL ASK FOR YOU
TO RAISE YOUR HANDS AND- THEN
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE. I'LL
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE- IT'S HARD
TO. REMEMBER THESE THINGS ACT
YOU'RE ACTUALLY IN THE- I KNOW
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE- WHEN
YOU'RE ACTUALLY SPEAKING SO-
YOU MAY GET A GENTLE REMINDER
FROM ME IF YOU SHOULD BE- IN A
POSITION- VIOLATE THESE VERY
IMPORTANT RULES- YOU'LL HAVE
ABOUT ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT- I WILL- AT A TIME IT
IS CLOSELY AS POSSIBLE- WE
TYPICALLY HAVE- A FAIR AMOUNT
OF PUBLIC COMMENT. IN BUDGET
SUB THREE AND UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE FIVE A TIME LIMITS THAT WE
HAVE TO ABIDE BY. OF BEFORE THE
OVERALL MEETING NOT JUST- FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE OR
RETURN YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR USE
TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME. THE
PALACE ON THE AGENDA AND ELLIE
OR APPEARING REMOTELY USING
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. AND I'D LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT WE ARE NOT
TAKING ANY VOTES IN COMMITTEE
TODAY AND YOU MAY NOTICE IN
YOUR- OF AGENDA THAT WE HAVE-
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T APPEARED
IN ARGENTA BEFORE IT'S CALLED
NON. PRESENTATION ITEMS AND-
THESE ARE ITEMS THAT WOULD
NORMALLY BE ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR BUT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TAKING ANY VOTE WE DIDN'T WANT
TO IMPLY. THAT THAT THERE WOULD
BE BY HAVING A VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR SO ITEMS THAT WOULD
NORMALLY BE ON VOTE ONLY ARE
CALLED NON PRESENTATION ITEMS.
EVERY ONE OF THESE ITEMS WILL
COME BACK AT A FUTURE MEETING
EITHER ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR. OR. FOR HEARING IF
NECESSARY BUT WE EXPECT THAT
MOST IF NOT ALL OF THEM WILL
COME BACK. AT A LATER DATE ON
VOTE ONLY SO IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE NON
PRESENTATION ITEMS YOU ARE MORE
THAN WELCOME TO. ASK THEM OF-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR THE
DEPARTMENT- THEY MAY NOT BE
PREPARED TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS HERE THIS MORNING
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T GATHER THE
RELEVANT STAFF AND DIDN'T-
ANTICIPATE THOSE QUESTIONS
AHEAD OF TIME. BUT THEY WILL BE
IN A POSITION TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS BETWEEN NOW AND THE
TIME THAT THEY ISSUES COME
BACK. THEY WILL COME BACK ON A
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR SO YOU HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY ALSO AT THAT
TIME TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS IF
YOU STILL HAVEN'T HAD A
SUFFICIENT ANSWER BUT- WE TRY
AND IN THIS- SUBCOMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE COVER SO MUCH
GROUND. WE ASK MEMBERS TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE- ASK YOUR
QUESTIONS OF DEPARTMENTS- LA-
AND- OUR OUR STAFF- ASK. YOUR
QUESTIONS AHEAD OF TIME TO GET
AS MANY QUESTIONS ANSWERED AS
POSSIBLE LEAVING ONLY CREDIT
ONES- THOSE ISSUES WERE YOU ONE
OF MY A POINT TO- OR HAVE YOUR-
ACOSTA. HER OF. LEAVING THOSE
SO FOR THE TIME OF HEARING. WE
ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC AT THE END
OF THE HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
THE PHONE NUMBER. TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND
SHOULD BE ALSO ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET NOT. PHONE NUMBER IS
AND ITS TOLL FREE. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE THAT YOU'LL NEED IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. I'LL REPEAT THOSE
NUMBERS SO WHEN WE DO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND WE HAVE
BURKE A STAFF MEMBER WHO WAS
THERE AND ABLE TO ASSIST YOU
AGAIN THAT PHONE NUMBER IS NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO NINE NINE THAT'S IF YOU
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THE OTHER
NUMBER SO THERE'S A LITTLE BACK
UP THERE. ANTA ON SO WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO WILL- BEGIN THE
HEARING AND TO- LET ME- ASK NOW
IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE- NON A PRESENTATION
ITEMS. I DO HAVE ONE. MISTER
SMITH IN REGARDS TO ISSUE
EIGHTEEN OF THOSE HIRED SIX NEW
POSITIONS WITH A COVERT
SITUATION IN THE LAST YEAR IN
OF PROBABLY THE EMPLOYEES NOT
BEING ABLE TO GET OUT IN THE
FIELD IF WE COULD ASK TO
SUSPEND THAT EFFECTIVE DATE FOR
ONE YEAR AND I KNOW YOU DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER BUT WHEN IT
COMES FORWARD REMOVED ENOUGH.
CONSIDER THAT. OKAY I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE- SOMEBODY
FROM MY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
WHO WILL NOT WOULD NOT WHO CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION BUT THAT
THEY'RE GETTING QUESTION. SINCE
THEY'RE NOT IN THE ROOM TO HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF- FINANCE- YEAH
GOOD MORNING A THIS SURGICAL
OUR PROBLEM DEPARTMENT PLANS
YEAH WILL DEFINITELY- WORK WITH
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD AND GET A
RESPONSE BACK THAT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THAT ALL. GREAT THANK
YOU- THEM WITHOUT WILL MOVE ON
TO- ITEMS TO BE HEARD OUR FIRST
ITEM IS THE ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
UNDER THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY PROP SIXTY EIGHT HABITAT
FUNDING. WE HAVE A PANEL OF
INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING PCA
MISTER FULLER FROM MY TLF-
BRIAN CASH ASSISTANCE SECRETARY
FOR ADMINISTRATION AND FINANCE
FROM THE A NATURAL SOURCES
AGENCY. JENNIFER NORRIS ALSO
AGENCY RACHEL ALORS FROM THE
ALEJO. SERGIO AGUILAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE
VOCAL FROM- VIA WHO- IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
WATER PORTFOLIO PROGRAM AT THE
NRA. IS THE DEPARTMENT GOING TO
PRESENT FIRST ON THIS OR-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT DOES THAT BRING CASH
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY- THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY WILL PRESENT FIRST
UNLESS- I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE-
DR- JENNIFER NORRIS WILL BE
DOING THE PRESENTATION AND
NANCY VOGEL WHO WILL ALSO BE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
JENNIFER. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING BRIAN. THERE WE GO WHY
DO YOU CAN YOU BE GET YOURSELF
A LITTLE BIT CLOSER TO THE
MICROPHONE AT. YOUR VOICE IS
JUST A LITTLE BIT FACT. SURE
THEY GOT BETTER I THINK SO.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JENNIFER NORRIS DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT THE
NATURIST FIRST AGENCIES REQUEST
FOR ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROPOSITIONS
IN SIXTY EIGHT FUNDS FOR OUR
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S RIVERS
STREAMS AND WATERSHEDS PROGRAM
FIFTY SEVEN FUNDS MULTI BENEFIT
WATER QUALITY WATERSHED
PROTECTION AND RESTORATION
PROJECTS TO IMPROVE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS AND
HABITATS. FOR CENTRAL VALLEY
SALMON STEELHEAD AND OTHER
SPECIES. MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
NATIVE FISH SPECIES ARE HIGHLY
THREATENED DUE TO HABITAT LOSS
AND DEGRADATION AS I'M SURE YOU
ALL KNOW. AND CLIMATE CHANGE IS
EXACERBATING THESE THREATS WITH
LONGER AND MORE FREQUENT
DROUGHTS REDUCED SPRING FLOWS
AND HIGHER SUMMER TEMPERATURES.
THESE FUNDS WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
THE URGENT WORK OF RESTORING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY RIVER
SYSTEMS TO HELP RECOVER THESE
IMPERILED SPECIES. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ALLOCATING THESE
FUNDS THROUGH A RIGOROUS AND
TRANSPARENT PUBLIC SOLICITATION
PROCESS. PROJECT WILL BE
SCREENED FOR THEIR ABILITY TO
DELIVER. QUICK DURABLE BENEFITS
TO TARGET SPECIES AND FOR
SUPPORT BY A WIDE VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND PARTNERS. WE
HAVE A BACKLOG OF MANY WORTHY
PROJECTS READY TO BE FUNDED
RIGHT AWAY WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
AND ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. WE HAVE A
PRESENTATION FROM A. I DO ALFA
ALEJO ANNUALLY- HAS SOME
COMMENTARY ON THIS. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS RACHEL EHLERS
FROM THE L. A. O. MISTER CARE
MEMBERS NICE TO SEE YOU ALL OF
THE MAIN QUESTION WE HAVE ON
THIS ISSUE FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
IS REALLY HOW MUCH DISCRETION
DO YOU WANT TO DEFER TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DECIDE HOW TO
SPEND THESE FUNDS AND HOW MUCH
GUIDANCE DO YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE. THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BOND IS REALLY VERY HIGH LEVEL
AND AB THE BUDGET BUILT A
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF DETAIL SO
YOU COULD CONSIDER ADDING
LANGUAGE REQUIRING A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM YOU
COULD CONSIDER ADDING LANGUAGE.
WRITING PROVIDING SOME PLANNERS
AROUND HOW YOU WANT THAT
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM TO BE
SCHEDULED TO BE APPLE ORIENTED
WHAT PRIORITIES WHAT- AREAS OF
FOCUS- AND ADDITIONALLY THE
BOND ALSO ALLOWS THESE FUNDS TO
BE USED FOR FIVE SPECIFIC
STATEWIDE OBLIGATIONS THOSE ARE
THE SOLVENCY THE LAKE TAHOE-CONTACT KLAMATH DAM COMPACT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
IMPROVEMENT ACT AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER RESTORATION
PROGRAM. SO YOU COULD ALSO
ALLOCATE SOME AMOUNT OF THIS
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR THOSE
PRIORITIES THREE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE SO- REALLY I THINK THE
MAIN MESSAGE WE WANT TO LEAVE
YOU WITH IS HOW MUCH
PRIORITIZATION DO YOU CARE
ABOUT WITH THESE FUNDS AND HOW
MUCH GUIDANCE AND DIRECTION. DO
YOU WANT TO PROVIDE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU.
QUESTION. I'D LIKE TO ASK A- I
GUESS IT WOULD BE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAID. WHY ARE THESE- OF
FUNDS NOT ALLOCATED THROUGH
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM. SURE
GOOD MORNING TERROR IN OUR
BORDERS AB RENTAL APARTMENTS-
WE KNOW OKAY AT AT AT THIS
POINT TIME AFTER RESOURCE
AGENCY IN IT DOESN'T TEND TO
ALLOCATE THESE FUNDS THROUGH A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM- TO
THE EXTENT THAT ADDITIONAL OUR
CONVERSATIONS ARE REQUESTED ON
pON POSSIBLE REGIONAL LANGUAGE
AS AS THE ONLY- MENTIONED HAPPY.
TO FOLLOW UP WITH STAFF TO
DISCUSS THE- GREAT THAT SAID TO
A- FOR ME TO READ. EVERYONE
THAT- WE WILL BE TAKING VOTES
ON THESE ISSUES TODAY SO
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE-
AND THEY WILL BE INFORMED. BY
BOTH THE STAFF REPORT- THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM OUR STAFF-
AND THE COMMENTS THAT YOU MAKE
TODAY- SO- FIVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- A REPORTS ON- ISSUE
NUMBER ONE. I WILL MOVE FURTHER
FORWARD. IN TWO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO WHICH IS- THESE- HAVE
VARIOUS OF A PROPOSES THAT ARE
FUNDED THROUGH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE. PLATE
FUND. JUST BRING CASH FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY- THE
MINISTRATION PROPOSES THE ITEMS
THAT ARE LISTED IN THE AGENDA
USING THE ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE
PLATE FUND. IN THE BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD OUR LEGAL
COUNSEL REVIEW- THESE USES OF
THE LPF AND THEY FELT LIKE THEY
WERE APPROPRIATE AND GIVEN THAT
THE SUPPORT IDENTIFIABLE
PROJECTS PROGRAMS THE SPECIFIC
COSTS THAT MEET THE PURPOSES
LISTED IN THE ELP OF STATUTE.
IN ADDITION THESE PROPOSALS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS FUNDED IN THE
PAST INCLUDING FUNDING THE
BOLSA CHICA RESTORATION PROJECT
IN THE CURRENT YEAR IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
IN FUNDING FOR THE SAN DIEGO
RIVER CONSERVANCY'S MAIN
OPERATING COSTS SINCE ITS
INCEPTION. AND WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE STAFF'S
ASSESSMENT IN THE AGENDA THAT
THE PROPOSAL SHOULD BE SHOULD
BE FUNDED AND WE WILL BE GLAD
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- DO WE HAVE- LMAO AVAILABLE.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BRAND BROWN WITH ALEJO-
YEAH WE IN LOOKING AT THIS
PROPOSAL WE IDENTIFIED TWO
ISSUES MOSTLY RELATED TO WHO-
THE LARGEST THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
NEW PROPOSAL FUNDED OUT OF YOUR
CABINETS CAN DO- THE STATE
DEPARTMENT FROM THE EXISTING
NATURAL RESOURCES BUILDING TO
THE NEW ONE THAT'S BEEN UNDER
CONSTRUCTION THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS OF THE COMMISSION DARDEN
NUMBER ONE IT IS- MISTER CASH
REFERENCE WE DID RAISE A
CONCERN. ABOUT WHETHER THOSE
OFF BETWEEN MAY BE CATEGORIZED
IT PRIMARILY ADMINISTRATIVE ARE
AN APPROPRIATE ALLOWABLE USE OF
THE LPF WHICH IN STATUE HAS
CERTAIN DESIGNATED PURPOSES
SUCH AS FOR THAT RESTORATION
PROTECTION OF ENDANGERED
SPECIES AND- AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION THE SECOND QUESTION
THAT WE REYES WAS- WHERE I
IDENTIFIED WAS SOME UNCERTAINTY
AROUND BE FINE CONDITION FOR. A
YEAR L. P. F. AND THIS IS
PARTLY BECAUSE THE MEDICATION
IS NOT YET CLOSE THE BOOKS ON
THE PRIOR YEAR SO THERE'S SOME
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT THE
STARTING POINT CONDITION IS-
GOING INTO THE BUDGET YEAR AND
THEN ALSO- SOME UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT RATHER THAN STATIC GIVEN
THE ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY THAT
THAT WE'RE ALL FACING- SO GIVEN
THESE TO YOU SHOULD BE
IDENTIFIED TWO OPTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER- THE
FIRST IS IT WOULD BE AN OPTION
TO SIMPLY SWAP. THE LPF- AND
FOR- FORTY EIGHT THAT CAN SO
THAT ALLOW YOU FORGET TO
GENERAL OF TO FUND THE- OTHER
RESEARCH. THAT AND USED A SEMI
AMOUNT OF THE LPF OTHER
PROGRAMS IN THE BUDGET THAT ARE
CLEARLY- CONSISTENT WITH
ALLOWABLE USES OF THE L. P. ARE
CONCERNED EXAMPLE MIGHT BE. A
FUNDING FOR PARKS DEFERED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS IN NET
NEUTRAL- ACTION THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE FUNDING OF THE
PROJECT BUT THEN ALSO WOULD
HAVE- NO IF. ACT ON IT EMPF FOR
GENERAL FUND IN TOTAL. I DON'T
MEAN IT WOULD IT WOULD ALSO NOT
HAVE- THE BENEFIT OF REDUCING
THE L. P. UP COST IF YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FINE
CONDITION SO WE COULD ALSO
OFFER A SECOND OPTION- IN THAT
IT. IS TO. TAKE THE COST FOR
THE NEW AND DEFER THOSE. UP
ACROSS ALL OF THE FUNDS THAT
SUPPORT THE RESOURCE AGENCY AN
APARTMENT IN THE BUILDING. DO
YOU TAKE THE FOUR AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS IN COST AND-
AND IT YOU SPREAD THAT ACROSS-
PRICE FOR THE TITLE FUND AS
WELL AS THE GENERAL FUND-THAT
WOULD HAVE BOTH THE BENEFIT OF
REDUCING COSTS FROM THE LPF.
AND THEN ALSO- WOULD HAVE A
TRADE OFF THOUGH- IF YOU WOULD
HAVE SOME MARGINAL INCREASES IN
ONE TIME COSTS. FOR THOSE OTHER
FINES. THE END THAT WE CAN GET
IN THE- THE FACT THAT THAT FOUR
AND A HALF MILLION. I IN MOST
CASES THAT WOULD BE. MANAGEABLE
BY THOSE FUNDS ON A ONE TIME
BASIS. THANK YOU. SELL IF I
COULD GET THE- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BACK BOB CAN'T WALK WHY
NOT- FOLLOW THE- A SUGGESTION
OF THE L. A. O. ON THIS ISSUE
THAT THAT- CONNECTIVE ITTY
BETWEEN THE IDEAL PIAF AND THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THAT ARE
FUNDED AND IN THAT IN THESE
ITEMS IS TENUOUS. AT BEST- AND
WE'VE HAD THIS ISSUE COME UP
REPEATEDLY IN THE PAST. WHERE
THE L. P. HALF IS- I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT
REALLY STRETCHES- THE ODDS OF
THE BOUNDS OF THE LAW TO USE
THESE FUNDS FOR THE PURPOSES
THAT ARE RECOMMENDED TODAY- WHY
NOT FROM THESE OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND OR DO THE KIND OF
SWAP. THAT OF THE ALLEY-
SUGGESTING. SURE YEAH BRAMBLE
PARK LANDS AND BIG QUESTIONS M.
AS IT RELATES TO. THE USE OF
YOUR YEAH AS AS THE FUNDS
SOURCE FOR THESE PROPOSALS IN
IN YOUR SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT.
THE SIMPSONS YOU CAN SEE WITH
THE SUIT HM. I GUESS JUST
STEPPING BACK A BIT ATHLETE
MISTER CAPTAIN JAMES I'M THAT
PART PART. OF THE DAY. BUDGET
ON PROCESS THE MINISTRY
EVALUATES. THESE WERE TO MAKE
SURE THAT FUNDS SOURCES AND
PROPOSED ACT ALIGNED WITH THE
FOR GIVEN STATUTE THAT AND- AND
THE STATUS OF AN- ADULT IT'S
ABOUT FUN THE SUIT SOME FACTORS
IT GOES AGAINST. YOU PROBABLY
OF ALL SORTS CAST OF THE PHONE
TO SUPPORT THE OFF THE
PROBLEMATIC RACISM ON MONDAY
THEN KIND OUR OVERALL BUDGET.
AND SO. I JUST WANT TO YOU CAN
SPEAK YOUR YEAH HAVING TO ASK
TO SUPPORT OUR- MISTER BROWN
WHICH IS. AND BEYEAH. NOT NOT
YET CLOSING BACK ASK YOUR FOR
YOU YEAH SENATE. PROVIDING. THE
FUND BALANCE THAT. EVAN IS
BEATING FASTER SAVING IN THAT
RESPECT- BUT AGAIN THAT KIND OF
YEAH IN MIND THE BROUGHT AT
GENERAL FUND ENDING COVERED BY
FRAMEWORK REALLY IT WILL BE
INTENT TO PER AND- THAT ANY
GIVEN THE CORPORATE. AND
BUSINESSES THAT ARE. AND
ECONOMIC- BUT BUT STILL. DEBTS
DESPITE THE SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
ARE STILL SOME CONSTRAINTS ARE
WHAT EFFECT. WHICH IS IN PART
WHY THE NEW TURNS YELLOW YES IT
A FUN THIS DIFFERENT ELIGIBLE.
AND WHILE ALSO KEEPING MY THAT
WE GET GENERAL FUND AVAILABLE
SOME OF THESE OTHER PARTS OF
THE QUESTION- OF. THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CONSTRUCTION AND
WE'LL ALWAYS BE- MISTER CAPTAIN
MENTION THAT. IDENTIFIES
PRODUCTS PROGRAM OF THE
ENTITIES THAT BEFELL. PROGRAMS
THAT I CAN FIND STAFF SO AND IT
IN THAT IT. GIVEN THAT
BACKGROUND INFORMATION THE
STAFF SUPPORTING PROGRAMS
IDENTIFIED- WHAT TYPE OF WORK
SUPPORTED BY APPLE. DID YEP AND.
WELL I THOUGHT I FRANKLY DON'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND THE
EXPLANATION BUT- IT IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT WE HAVE A HISTORY WITH
THE L. P. HALF OF- THINKING OF
IT AS A PART OF MONEY THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO- FILL THE GAP- AND
IN THIS CASE- FILL THE GAP USES
WHEN IT COMES TO ADMINISTRATION
AN ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS-
WITHOUT THERE BEING ANY
OVERRIDING STRATEGY FOR THEIR
USE IT'S JUST THIS IS JUST LIKE
OUT OF FUND THAT'S THERE. TO
SPRINKLE MONEY AROUND IN THE
BUDGET BUT WITHOUT ANY
STRATEGIC PURPOSE. AB AND- I
REALLY THINK WE NEED TO RE OF
RETHINK THE APPROACH THAT WE
HAVE ON THIS. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YES MISTER BENNETT HAD.
DESIGNATION OF THE SENATE
FOREIGN RELATIONS. THE HAS TO
HAVE WANTED TO BE PROBABLY ON-
NUMBER PROGRAMS OF THE THAN
WHAT THEY HAVE TO THERE I GUESS.
WELL WHY DON'T WE ASK THE OF-
THE H. FOR L. A. THIS IS BRIAN
CASH FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY- THERE'S BEEN A HISTORY
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE LPF
OF FUNDING PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS THAT- THE PROVIDE FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES RESTORATION
AND ALSO FOR. THE
ADMINISTRATION OF PROGRAMS
WITHIN THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS- THE AGENCY
PROVIDES A REPORT EVERY YEAR TO
THE LEGISLATURE ALONG WITH THE-
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF THE
USES FOR THE FOR THE FUND AND-
A REPORT WAS PROVIDED AT THE-
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR TO STAFF
SHOWING HOW THE FUND WAS USED
THROUGHOUT THE DIFFERENT.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE
FUND. SOME OF THE- FUNDING IS
USED TO SUPPORT THE- STAFF
COSTS FOR THE AGENCIES FOR
ESPECIALLY FOR CONSERVANCIES-
AND THE WORK THAT THEY DO DOES
PROMOTE- ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION ACQUISITION
PROTECTION. AND OTHER ITEMS
THAT ARE SUPPORTED IN THE YEP
YEP YEP STATUTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT I'LL JUST POINT OUT THAT-
AND- MISTER SMITH YOU CHASE
BURKE KIND OF THE SAME THING UP
AS A NEW GUY UP HERE AND
ACRONYMS I WANNA MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE NRA I A
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY FOR ONE
THING BUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
LICENSE PLATE FUND SHOULD BE
USED FOR ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
THE MOVE IS A ONE TIME- COST.
AND IT SHOULD COME OUT THE
GENERAL FUND. SO- HOPE THE LMAO
OF RECONSIDERS AT. FOR THE
AGENCY THIS IS A MORE IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAN- MIGHT SEEM ON THE
SURFACE BECAUSE THERE ARE
NUMEROUS SPECIAL FUNDS AND MANY
OF THEM ARE TREATED THE SAME
WAY- AND- ALASKA- ARE A
COMMITTEE STAFF- NOT NOW BUT-
IN BETWEEN NOW AND THE NEXT
MEETING PERHAPS WE CAN BE
INFORMED WHAT THOSE OTHER
SPECIAL FUNDS ARE- SO THAT WE
START TO THINK ABOUT- HOW YOU
CAN USE THEM A LITTLE BIT MORE
STRATEGICALLY. THE TIRE
RECYCLING FEE IS ANOTHER GOOD
EXAMPLE OF WHERE THIS HAPPENS-
IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS SO WE'RE GONNA- JUST
TO BE CLEAR WE'RE GONNA HOLD
PUBLIC COMMENT TO THE END OF
THE HEARING SO PEOPLE WILL BE
ABLE TO- PROVIDE COMMENT ON UP-
ALL WE HAVE A RELATIVELY
LIMITED- A CALENDAR THIS MORE
SO I THINK- RATHER THAN GO. ONE
BY ONE OF WE CAN JUST DO THEM
ALL AT THE END. THE- OF THE ACT
OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING. SO THAT
THAT TAKES US TO ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL LAW
OF LIFE- BIODIVERSITY
ENHANCEMENTS FEATURED ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS THE WILDLIFE
HABITAT RESTORATION PUBLIC-
AGREES FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE FOR A. TO
THE BUDGET REQUEST FROM THE
GOVERNOR. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
THIS IS CHUCK BONHAM AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH A LOT OF
BLOOD GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
MISTER BOTTOM. YEAH I MISS YOU
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU I WISH I
WAS SITTING EVERYONE IN PERSON
IT'S A LITTLE BIT WEIRD DANIEL
IN IT THIS WAY. YES AND IT
MIGHT GET A LITTLE BIT WEIRD-
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO SEE.
WITH THE CONFIRMATION OF YOUR
STAFF WHETHER I CAN SHARE MY
SCREEN. AND I WANT TO CONFIRM
ONE THING WITH THE CHAIR
GETTING I'M GETTING AND NODDING
YES THAT YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SHARE SCREEN PHILIP. LET'S GO
FOR IT. OKAY AND TO CONFIRM- I
WOULD FIRST GIVE YOU A QUICK.
EXHORTATION OF OUR SERVICE
BASED BUDGET REPORTS AND THEN
TURN TO OUR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL. IS THAT- YOUR
UNDERSTANDING AS WELL YES. OKAY
GREAT ME ONE SECOND SEE IF I
CAN PULL THIS OFF. IT ARE YOU
SEEING A SLIDE THAT IS THE
INTRODUCTORY SLIDE REPORTS ARE
NOW WE'RE SEEING YOUR INITIALS.
OKAY IF THIS DOES NOT. WORK WE
WILL SKIP. STILL JUST SAYING MY
INITIALS OUT NOT- YOUR- OUR
POINT IS UP ON THE SCREEN.
PERFECT A LOT OF BEAUTIFUL UP
PICTURES OF NATURE JUST WEST
LIKE THIS WHAT WE LIKE TO DO
FOR ME. THIS MIGHT BE THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PART OF MY DAY
HAVING GOTTEN THROUGH THE SHARE
SCREEN HERE SO. REAL QUICKLY-
YOU'LL SEE ON THE SCREEN. THE
DEPARTMENT'S MISSION STATEMENT
I HAPPEN TO THINK. THIS IS ONE
OF THE MOST INSPIRING VISIONS
OF ANY GOVERNMENT AGENCY. AND
IT REALLY IS AN EXPRESSION OF
THE EXCEPTIONALISM OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE NATURE OF THE
WEALTH OF OUR NATURE IS
EXCEPTIONAL IN THE STATE. WE'VE
KNOWN THAT FOREVER OUR
INDIGENOUS PARTNERS NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES HAVE KNOWN THAT
SINCE TIME IMMEMORIAL. THAT
NATURAL WEALTH FUELS ARE
THRIVING ECONOMY AND THAT
NATURAL WEALTH GIVES ASSISTANCE
OF PLACE IN A SENSE OF PURPOSE
IN THE SENSE OF IDENTITY. AS
CALIFORNIANS. WE'VE BEEN ON A
LONG JOURNEY YOU'VE BEEN ON
THIS JOURNEY WITH US. YOU SET
US IN THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
MOST RECENT PHASE OF THIS
JOURNEY WITH THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. YOU
ASKED US TO GO COMPLETE SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING THAT'S WHAT S.
B. B. STANDS FOR WE HIRED THE
NATIONAL CONSULTING FIRM
DELOITTE WHO HAS DONE THIS
AROUND THE NATION. AND THE
GOALS OF THE EFFORT YOU STATUS
ON SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WE'RE TO ANALYZE THOSE FOUR
ASPECTS. YOU SEE HERE DESCRIBED
AS THE GOALS. SO MOVING TO THE-
SLIDE. WE STARTED WITH THE
RETHINKING WHO WE WERE WE
CONVENED AN EXTERNAL IT VISOR
COMMITTEE THAT IS A DIVERSE
REPRESENTATION OF. PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ENGAGE WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT AND WE REALIZED WE
WERE EXPLAINING WHAT WE DO WELL
ENOUGH FOR PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THEY'RE CONNECTED TO OUR
DEPARTMENT. SO OVER THE COURSE
OF TWO YEARS WE STARTED WITH
THE RE DESCRIBING OURSELVES AND
ORGANIZING OURSELVES AROUND THE
POOR SERVICES UC DESCRIBED IN
THIS SLIDE USING PLAINER
LANGUAGE SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
WHO WE ARE WHAT WE DO AND WHAT
OUR FUTURE LOOKS LIKE. AND THE
RESULT OF THIS PROCESS REALLY
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES WE CREATED
AN INTERNAL TEAM EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP MYSELF THROUGH OUR
EXECUTIVE TEAM. OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY OF OUR SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS IN ART IT'S A T. AND
THEN WE DID TWO YEARS OF
EXHAUSTIVE ANALYTICS WORKING
WITH THE BOARD. WE BROUGHT
THOSE EIGHT SERVICE AREAS INTO
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
TASKS THAT WE DO TO ACHIEVE OUR
OBJECTIVES IN THOSE AREAS. WE
NOW HAVE ON IT OR TO EXCEL
SPREADSHEET THAT'S FOUR FIVE
HUNDRED PAGES THE TRACKS EACH
OF THESE TASKS WE WENT OUT AND
SAW ALL OF THE DATA AROUND THE
LABOR HOURS NEEDED. TO
ACCOMPLISH THOSE TASKS TO
ACHIEVE BOTH OUR MISSION AND
THE LABOR HOURS RELATIVE TO OUR
CURRENT SERVICE LEVELS ENDED AT
THE END OF THIS PROCESS WE
ANALYZED OUR TOP TEN MOST
IMPORTANT COMPLICATED ONES. TO
DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATENESS
OF HOW WE'RE USING THOSE FUNDS
AND THE RELATIVE USE OF THOSE
FUNDS BACK TO OUR TASKS OUR
CURRENT SERVICE AND OUR MISSION
LEVEL OF SERVICE. AND HERE'S
WHAT YOU GET WHEN YOU GO
THROUGH SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
YOU GET ON UP BILITY. TO
QUANTIFY YOUR WORK WITHIN A
PROGRAM AREA WHICH YOU SEE
REFLECTED ON ONE SIDE OF THE
SCREEN HERE THE DARKER COLOR IS
A DATA DRIVEN WAY FOR YOU TO
UNDERSTAND YOUR CURRENT LEVEL
OF SERVICE. PAGE MARKED AGAINST
THE TASKS YOU WERE DOING AT
EIGHT LABOR OUR LEVEL AND THEN
YOU GET A DATA DRIVEN WAY TO
UNDERSTAND YOUR MISSION LEVEL.
THE GAP BETWEEN YOUR CURRENT
AND IF YOU WERE DOING ALL THE
THINGS NECESSARY TO MEET YES
SIGN. AND THEN WHAT YOU SEE IN
THIS BUBBLE CELL ON THE SLIDE.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF WAYS TO
RESPOND TO THE GAP THAT YOUR
DAD IT ILLUSTRATES. YOU CAN
LOOK AT YOUR MISTER AND YOUR
POLICIES YOUR MANDATES PERHAPS
SOME OF THEM ARE OUTDATED SOME
OF THEM COULD USE
CLARIFICATION. YOU CAN LOOK AT
THE INTERNAL YOU CAN SPARE CHIU
NAVAL OF YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOU COULD PUSH YOURSELF TO.
CREATE YOUR OWN INTERNAL
EFFICIENCIES. YOU CAN GO TO
YOUR EXTERNAL PARTNERS AND
THINK THROUGH. WAYS IN WHICH
PARTNERSHIPS CAN OFFLOAD SOME
OF YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
APPROPRIATELY AND DEAL WITH THE
GAP. AND YOU CAN LOOK AT
INVESTMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY AND
EQUIPMENT OF COURSE YOU CAN
ALSO LOOK AT LABOR AS A WAY TO
COVER THAT GAP. IN HERE'S WHAT
YOU FIND. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DEPARTMENT'S ANALYSIS WHICH IS
NOW BEING COMPLETED OVER TWO
YEARS. WORKING WITH MOST OF
YOUR STAFF ABROAD EXTERNAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE GROUP. AND
HERE IS- DATA DRIVEN
REPRESENTATION OF THE FINES WE
SUBMITTED OUR FINAL REPORT TO
YOU LAST WEEK. ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION IS INCLUDED IN THAT
REPORT AND THE FINDINGS FRANKLY
IT'S NOT SURPRISING. ALL OF US
HAVE KNOWN FOR A LONG TIME. THE
DEPARTMENT'S ASSIGNMENTS ITS
MANDATES ITS MISSIONS EXCEED
ITS CAPACITY AND IT'S
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SUPPORT. IF
YOU LOOK AT AND WHAT WE FILED
WITH YOU LAST WEEK APPENDIX A-
IS A LONG LIST OF ALL THE PRIOR
REPORTS THAT HAVE TAKEN AND
LOOK T THIS ISSUE THE FIRST
REPORT IS NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
THAT REPORT SAYS UNFUNDED
MANDATES ARE A PROBLEM. YOU THE
LEGISLATURE OF ACTUALLY AMENDED
OUR CODE TO EXPRESSLY SAY IN
THE FISH AND GAME CODE THAT OUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGE. IS ARE UNDER
FUNDED CAPACITY. AND HERE IS A
VISUAL DESCRIPTION OF THE GAPS.
WELL ON ONE SIDE YOU SEE WHERE
THE GAP IS SMALLEST
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT THAT
MAKES SENSE WE CHARGE
INTERNALLY ACROSS ALL OF OUR
SERVICE AREAS TO ENSURE WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT IN THE MINISTRY OF
SUPPORT. LOOKING JUST AT THAT
THE 73% NUMBER. FIGURE
INDICATES THE LEVEL OF SERVICE
WORKERS PROVIDING AND THE 27%
REPRESENTS THE GAP TO ACHIEVE
THE MISSION LEVEL OF SERVICE
AND IF YOU GO ALL THE WAY OVER
TO THE OTHER SIDE. YOU'LL SEE
WHERE OUR GAPS ARE LARGEST IN
OUR SERVICE CURRENTLY IS THE
LEAST RELATIVE TO OUR MISSION.
ADD THIS TO WHILE FOR ME
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTING IS
SOMEWHAT NOT SURPRISING. THE
GROWTH OF THE DEPARTMENT
HISTORICALLY OVER TIME IN OUR
MANDATES IS IT IN THIS ARENA.
BESTIES OF HABITAT CONSERVATION
WHEN YOU CONSIDER OUR
TRADITIONAL ACTIVITIES WERE
REALLY FOCUSED YOU KNOW FIFTY
YEARS AGO A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
ON BUSTING THE HUNTER IN THE
ANGLER THAT WAS POACHING
ENFORCING HUNTING AND FISHING
CODE. PROVISIONS NOW WE DO SO
MUCH MORE AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THEN WE COULD HAVE CONTEMPLATED
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO- WHEN THE
BOARD OF FIFTIES COMMISSIONERS
WAS CREATED. THESE CATEGORIES
OVER ON THE FAR SIDE PERMITTING
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION IN
SPECIES AND HABITAT
CONSERVATION I'VE ALSO BEEN
MORE RECENTLY THE HISTORICAL
AREAS HARDEST. TO FIND A
SUSTAINABLE PERMANENT ONGOING
FUND SOURCE FOR NEXT SLIDE AND
THEN I'M DONE- TWO SLIDES THIS
IS THE SAME. CHALLENGE PROBLEM
NOW DESCRIBES FOCUSED ON HOURS
OF LABOR. IT LAYS OUT ROUGHLY
THIS SIMILAR ARE YOU GO ALL THE
WAY OVER TO SPECIES AND HABITAT
CONSERVATION YOU SEE THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES THERE. EVEN
THOUGH THAT IS ACTUALLY AN
ARENA WHERE WE'RE DOING THE
MOST LABOR HOURS. THAT'S THE
INFORMATION WHAT I THINK IS
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANT. OUR
DEPARTMENT HAS TURNED A CORNER
WE'RE REALLY OLD INSTITUTION
WE'RE TRYING TO PREPARE FOR THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY YOUR
ASSIGNMENT GIVEN TO US FOR
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING HAS
REALLY ALLOWED US THE BUS A BIG
PROBLEM WE HAD I DON'T THINK
HISTORICALLY WE'VE BEEN
TRANSPARENT. I DON'T THINK
HISTORICALLY WE'VE BEEN DATA
DRIVEN AND THIS TWO YEAR EFFORT
HAS ALLOWED US TO BECOME SUCH
MORE TRANSPARENT AND OPEN ABOUT
OUR DATA WORKING WITH YOU AND
OUR STAKEHOLDERS. TO THE
CHALLENGE WE HAVE. THESE ARE
THE FINDINGS HERE WHICH I JUST
MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO AS A
GENERAL MATTER OUR CURRENT
STAFFING IS SUFFICIENT TO
ACCOMPLISH ABOUT 36% OF OUR
MISSION LEVEL NEEDS. NOW THIS
IS NOT A ONE TIME ENDEAVOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. MY LAST SLIDE
HERE ABOUT DATA ANALYTICS.
YOU'VE TOLD US TO DO SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING WE'VE ACTUALLY
INSTITUTIONALIZED. I'VE HEARD A
FULL TIME DATA MANAGER. EVERY
YEAR WE WILL UPDATE THIS
INFORMATION THAT I'VE JUST
PRESENTED TO YOU TO REFRESH THE
CURRENT SERVICE LETTER DATA.
EVERY FIVE YEARS WE WILL UPDATE
THE MISSION LEVEL DATA.
INSTANTANEOUSLY WE WILL BE ABLE
TO ENGAGE WITH YOU AND YOUR
BUDGET STAFF TO PRODUCE VISUALS
LIKE THIS. WE'VE TRAINED ALL OF
OUR MOST IMPORTANT LEADERS
ACROSS ALL LEVELS OF THE
DEPARTMENT. THAT THIS IS OUR
NEW TOOL IT'S OUR NEW WAY OF
ORGANIZING OUR INSTITUTION. AT
A MINIMUM WHILE WE STILL HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING CHALLENGE
AHEAD OF US WE'VE CHANGED THE
CULTURE OF THE DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE OF Y'ALL'S INSTRUCTION.
YOUR YOUR TO TAKE US ON THIS
JOURNEY. SO SURE LET ME STOP
THERE. THAT'S THE PRESENTATION.
AND LET ME SEE IF I CAN SEGUE
BACK OVER TO MY FACE. PURPOSES
OF WHEN WE TRANSITION TO THE B.
C. P. AND PARTS OF THIRTY
QUESTIONS ON THE PRESENTATION
PART. YEAH- HI I'M GONNA CALL
YOU IN A SECOND MISTER BENNETT
BUT- IF YOU DON'T MIND BUT- I
WON A LEAD WITH- I SENT SOME
COMMENTS- MR BONHAM- YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THIS THE
RESULTS COME AS NO SURPRISE BUT
THE- WAY OF LAID OUT THE- THE
FINDINGS AND THE STRUCTURE.
AROUND THEM- I THINK IS VERY
VERY HELPFUL- YOU HAVE- USE THE
WORD SAID THAT- YOU'VE TURNED
THE CORNER AND- I HAVE TO SAY I
DON'T I DON'T THINK SO-
BECAUSE- OF KNOWING WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS ONLY PART OF THE
SOLUTION NOW IN ORDER TO REALLY
TURN THE CORNER WE NEED TO NOW-
YOU KNOW HOW YOU ADDRESS THESE
VERY VERY SERIOUS FUNDING GAPS.
AND WHILE THE RECOMMENDATIONS-
ADJUSTED TO A ONE TIME FUNDING
CAN- HELP ADDRESS AT LEAST
TEMPORARILY SOME OF THESE GAPS
THE REAL SOLUTION AS- FINDING
FUNDING OUR ONGOING BASIS TO
ADDRESS THE GAPS AND ON THAT
ISSUE. THERE'S I'M NOT LETTING
THIS AT YOUR DOORSTEP
NECESSARILY- DIRECTOR BONHAM-
BUT YOU'RE THE DIRECTOR- I I'VE
JUST A LITTLE BIT DUMBFOUNDED
HERE THAT THERE IS LIKE NO
PROPOSAL THERE IS NO SUGGESTION
ABOUT WHAT FOLLOWS- SO THAT WE
GET TO A PLACE- WHERE YOU'RE
VERY. IMPORTANT DEPARTMENT WITH
A THAT ADDRESSES SO MANY
IMPORTANT NEEDS AND THE STATE
GETS THE FUNDING THAT IT
DESERVES AND- THAT'S WHAT'S
DRIVEN THIS PROCESS FROM THE
GET GO AS THE FACT THAT WE KNOW
THE FUNDING. ISN'T THERE WE'VE
TRIED A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT-
APPROACHES TO A WE LOOKED AT A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT APPROACHES
TO PROVIDING THAT FUNDING- BUT
IT- IS A VERY SURPRISING TO ME
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
TAKEN THIS OPPORTUNITY AND SAID
OKAY NOW WE KNOW WHERE THE GAPS
ARE- AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE MUCH MORE.
EFFECTIVE IN ADDRESSING THOSE
GAPS. SURE CAN YOU HEAR ME. YOU
HAVE OKAY I'M SORRY I'M HAVING
A HARD TIME ON MY END WITH THE
CAPITAL IF IT AT THE ENTIRE AND
IT'S NOT JUST YOU BUT THE PRIOR
PRESENTATION WITH A LITTLE BIT
FAINT- AND IT CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO- TO HEAR IT'S TIME SO- WE
WON'T THINK YOU'RE YELLING AT
US IF YOU GO A LITTLE. SO WHEN
I MENTIONED ROUNDING THE CORNER
CORNER LET ME LET ME VERY MUCH
FOCUSED THAT AND WHAT I MEANT
TO SAY WAS WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE BEEN BRACED
THE SERVICE BASED BUDGET IDEA
THE INSTRUCTION TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT TO REALLY GET
GRANULAR ON WHO WE ARE AND HOW
WE DO IT THE DATA DRIVEN
APPROACH THAT THAT'S WHAT I
MEANT WITH ROUND THE CORNER I
KNOWLEDGE I STIPULATE AND I
UNDERSTAND. YOU'RE VERY SERIOUS
QUESTION ABOUT WHERE'S THE
SOLUTION AND I AM VERY MUCH
PREPARED TO TALK ABOUT THAT
TODAY TO THE EXTENT I CAN AS WE
SEGUE INTO THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL- THAT'S THE NEXT PART
OF MY ISSUE AN AGENDA ITEM
TODAY GREAT I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING IT AND MR BANNON HAVE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER- MR BONHAM- I DON'T WANT
TO BELABOR GO INTO THE DETAIL
RIGHT NOW BUT I WOULD LIKE TO.
ASK YOU TO HAVE HAVE YOUR
STAFF- REPAIR THE ANSWER TO
THIS QUESTION YOUR BOTTOM TWO
CATEGORIES WHICH IS SPECIES.
CONSERVATION AND THEN THE
PERMITTING- CATEGORIES ARE.
CATEGORIES THAT YOU'RE HAVING
THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS WITH I
WOULD LIKE TO GET. SOME KIND OF
ANALYSIS OF JUSTIN WHAT ARE THE
MAJOR THINGS THAT ARE NOT
HAPPENING THAT YOU'RE
IDENTIFYING- NEED TO HAPPEN IN
THOSE TWO CATEGORIES- WHAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE WHAT YOU'VE IDENTIFIED
AS NEEDS TO BE DONE- AND IS NOT
HAPPENING SO THAT WE CAN.
PERHAPS BRING THAT ALIVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE- FOR US SO I
WITHOUT IT TAKING A MORE TIME
HERE JUST WILL ALERT YOU THAT
LIKE TO HAVE THAT INFORMATION
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR YOU
TO PROVIDE THANK YOU. MISTER
BENNETT WE'D BE GLAD TO- AND
THAT IS A BENEFIT OF THIS
PROCESS WE'VE GONE THROUGH WE
CAN ACCESS THAT DATA MUCH MORE
READILY. AND PROVIDED BASED ON
QUESTIONS LIKE THE ONE YOU
JUST. ASKED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND BEFORE YOU PROCEED INTO
THE NEXT PART OF YOUR
PRESENTATION I WANT TO WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG WHO-
DOESN'T NEED TO BE HERE BUT- AS
THE- A NEWLY APPOINTED VICE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE-
IS AN ALTERNATE MEMBER OF. OF
THE STUFF COMMITTEE. HELLO I
HAVE OBSERVED- BEFORE THAT- MR
FONG'S FOLLOWING MR OBERNOLTE-
AT THE A BUDGET COMMITTEE MEANS
THAT- OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE IS
THE FEEDER COMMITTEE FOR A-
VICE CHAIR POSITION OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND- THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN BE VERY PROUD
OF BUT IT'S GOOD TO SEE MR FONG.
DIRECTOR BOND BACK TO YOU.
GREAT SO NOW TURNING TO OUR
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL- THE
PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU THIS
MORNING I BELIEVE. DOES RELATE
TO MY EARLIER PRESENTATION
FIRST THIS STATE IS SO
EXCEPTIONAL I LOVE IT. AND THE
REASON WHY I LOVE IT SO MUCH
AND IT'S SO EXCEPTIONAL IS THE
WEALTH OF OUR NATURE OUR PLANTS
AND OUR ANIMALS WE HAVE MORE
TYPES OF THOSE PLANTS AND
ANIMALS THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE UNION. THE FACT WE HAVE
MORE PLANTS THAT ARE FOUND
NOWHERE ELSE IN THE GLOBE. THEN
ALMOST ALL THE OTHER STATES
COMBINED. THAT IS WHAT
BIODIVERSITY MEANS IT'S YOUR
WEALTH OF NATURE. AND WHAT YOU
SEE TODAY IS A PROPOSAL TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS INTO OUR
DEPARTMENTS WHICH HONOR THAT
EXCEPTIONALISM. THESE
INVESTMENTS ALLOW US TO BECOME
MORE CLIMATE RESILIENT THEY
ALLOWS TO MODERNIZE ITS MANY OF
THE THINGS WE DO AND THE ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS ARE A WAY IN
WHICH YOU CAN START TO CHIP
AWAY AT THE GAP BETWEEN YOUR
SERVICE LEVEL IN YOUR MISSION
REQUIREMENTS. SO THE PROPOSAL
IS FOR A TOTAL OF FORTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. FORTY ONE
FORTY TWO MILLION OF THAT IS
ONE TIME INVESTMENT FROM THE
GENERAL FUND ABOUT THREE POINT
FOUR THREE POINT THREE MILLION.
OF THAT IS A REDIRECTION OF
PROPOSITION TWELVE FUNDING. NOW
IT'S ON WISE FOR ME IS DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT EVER REJECT
ONE TIME FUNDS WHEN THEY'RE
OFFERED THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE NEED THEM. THE L.
A. O. OFFICE REPORT ON THIS
ITEM CONCLUDES IT'S A PRUDENT
AND REASONABLE THING TO DO. USE
ONE TIME INVESTMENTS TO MAKE
CHANGE TO REDUCE YOUR GAP.
SHARE I ACKNOWLEDGE THIS IS NOT
THE FULL LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTION I JUST SPEAKING
PERSONALLY AS DIRECTOR HERE'S
WHAT I HAVE TO THE DRUG THROUGH
OR GONE THROUGH I'VE WORKED
WITH YOU ALL TO RAISE FEES ON
CERTAIN SECTORS. RAISING FEES
ON COMMERCIAL FISHING WAS
PARTICULARLY BRUTAL AT A MOMENT
IN TIME. I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
PROPOSALS TO UTILIZE THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT TO SOLVE THE
DEPARTMENTS LONG TERM FUNDING.
NEEDS I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN RE
PURPOSING CAL TIRED RECYCLE
FUNDS FOR THE SAME NEED. L.
LAST YEAR SOME OF THESE ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS I'M PROPOSING
TODAY. ACTUALLY HAD TO BE TABLE
BECAUSE OF THE REMARKABLE
ECONOMIC SITUATION WE
EXPERIENCE IN MAY OF LAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF COVERT. SO HERE'S
HOW WE WOULD USE THIS ONE TIME
INVESTMENT. WE WILL TAKE ABOUT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND WE
WOULD FAST INTO THE SPACE OF
HUMAN WILDLIFE CONFLICTS. WE
GOT ALMOST FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE STATE WE HAVE ABOUT
SEVEN THOUSAND WILDLIFE
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN PEOPLE AND
BEARS AND MOUNTAIN LIONS AND
OTHER ANIMALS EACH YEAR. WE CAN
INVEST IN DOING THINGS LIKE
CONSTRUCTING MORE TRAPS FOR
MOUNT LINES SO THAT WHEN WE
CAPTURE AMOUNT LANDED SEDATED
IN SOMEONE'S BACKYARD IN LOS
ANGELES. WE CAN'T RESPOND MORE
QUICKLY AND MOVE THAT ANIMAL
BACK INTO THE WILDERNESS WE
WOULD TAKE FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND PURCHASED A
NEW FIXED WING AIRCRAFT. WE
HAVE ABOUT SEVEN PLANES ALL OF
THEM DATE TO THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES AN ADDITIONAL PLANE
WOULD BE A PRUDENT INVESTMENT
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO INCREASE
OUR WORK FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE'RE
FLYING ALONG THE COAST.
MONITORING THE MIGRATION OF
WHALES SO THAT WE CAN MANAGE
OUR DUNGEON THIS CRAP FISHERY
IN WALES AND AVOID INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN THE TWO DYNAMICS. WE
TAKE SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
WE MODERNIZE OUR FISH
HATCHERIES A GOOD EXAMPLE IS.
WE CURRENTLY USE A LOT OF STAFF
HOURS TO REMOVE DEAD ACHES FROM
THE HATCHERY FISH BY HAND TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF FUNGUS TO
LIVE X. CONVERTED TO EXHORTING
AUTOMATED MACHINES WILL MANAGE
OUR STAFF HOURS BETTER. AND
ALLOW US TO SHRINK. THAT GAP IN
THAT SERVICE AREA. FROM THERE
WE TAKE ABOUT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND WE- MODERNIZE HOW
WE MANAGE OUR OWN STATE
WILDLIFE AREA WETLANDS WE HAVE
A LOT OF OUTDATED DIESEL PUMPS
IN THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE.
PEOPLE HAVE TO DRIVE OUT TO
THEM AND START THEM. WE'RE
FINDING IN SOME PLACES WHEN WE
CONVERT THAT OPERATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SOLAR ARRAYS.
WE REDUCE OUR CLIMATE
FOOTPRINT. AND WE AUTOMATE OUR
SYSTEM AND WE CAN MANAGE OUR
WETLANDS RESPONSIVE TO GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S EXECUTIVEORDER AND
DASH EIGHTY TWO DASH TWENTY.
WHICH IS GOING TO BE REALLY
RELEVANT FOR THE THIRTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE DIVERSITY WORK THE
MANAGER ON STATE LANDS FOR
BIODIVERSITY BENEFITS. WE TAKE
ABOUT FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND COMPLETE IN THE
NORTH COAST. SOMETHING WE
COMPETITION MAPPING THIS
PRODUCES MULTIPLE BENEFITS IT'S
THE DATA SETS INDUSTRY RELIES
ON WEDNESDAY SITE PROJECTS TO
GO THROUGH PERMITTING. AND IT'S
ALSO THE BIOLOGICAL DATA SET TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS CONSERVED IN
THE STATE AND WHAT MIGHT BE
CONSERVING. RELATIVES OF THE
THIRTY BY THIRTY ASSIGNMENT. WE
TAKE FOUR POINT MILLION DOLLAR
DOLLARS AND WE- PURCHASE A
SPECIALLY MADE LARGE OFFSHORE
PATROL VESSEL FOR OUR MARINE
LAW ENFORCEMENT WORK. ALONG THE
COAST WE TAKE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION OF THE GENERAL FUND.
AND ANOTHER AMOUNT OF ABOUT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
PROP TWELVE. AND WE WOULD SPEND
IT ON OUR OWN PROPERTIES TO
INCREASE THE USE OF OUR
PROPERTIES FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AROUND CALIFORNIA.
FRANKLY WE'VE DOT DONE A GREAT
JOB OF THAT HISTORICAL. WE HAVE
PROPERTIES THAT ARE NEAR AND
PROXIMITY TO LARGE URBAN AREAS
WE HAVEN'T INTRODUCED OUR
PROPERTIES TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE INTEND TO ENGAGE
WITH OUR TRIBAL PARTNERS. AND
USE THESE LANDS AS A PATHWAY TO
EDUCATE AND OUTREACH TO PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA OUR DEPARTMENT
TYPICALLY IS SERVING AND NEEDS
TO DO BETTER AT SERVING. AND
THEN FINALLY WE USE ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO MODERNIZE. THE PLATFORMS OF
OUR REGULATION AND INFORMATION
SYSTEMS FOR HUNTERS AND ANGLERS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE
AWAY FROM- OF THE PAPER OLD
SCHOOL APPROACH AND TO THE
ABILITY TO PUT ALL THIS
INFORMATION ON MOBILE A
ACCESSIBLE YOUR DIGITAL
PLATFORMS FOR BOTH THE BENEFIT
OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE
FIELD AND THE CUSTOMER OF THE
HUNTER AND- THE ANGLER. THAT'S
WHERE I AM RIGHT NOW. SHARE I
KNOW YOU MAY HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE LARGER ISSUE. ALSO ON
THE CALL SERGIO AGUERO AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU CAN
HELP FEEL BILLS AS WELL. THANK
YOU- AND YOU'RE RIGHT AND I DO
HAVE QUESTIONS AND I THINK IT
BOILS DOWN TO A CONCERN I DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM PERSONALLY- AT
LEAST A- YOU KNOW THIS ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OF FINES ALL
OF THE PROPOSALS THAT YOU'RE
MAKING FOR IT- THESE
EXPENDITURES ALL THE PROJECTS
ARE VALUABLE. HI YOU STARTED
OUT TO- WITH WELL MIGRATION
AND- OF THE CONFLICT WITH THE
DENTIST SO- CRAB SEASON AND
THAT AS YOU KNOW SOMETHING WE
WORKED ON TOGETHER AS YOU KNOW
PERSONALLY NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART BUT ALL OF THESE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT ALL THE THINGS THAT
YOU PROPOSED TO FUND. ACT I
THINK ARE IMPORTANT PRIORITIES-
WHAT GOES ON SAID IS HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO ADDRESS THE- LONG
TERM STRUCTURAL ISSUES THAT ARE
BROUGHT OUT IN. IN VERY BROAD
RELIEF- THROUGH THE REPORT
THAT- THAT YOU COMMISSIONED AND
RECEIVED. AND YOU KNOW FOR
THAT- I DON'T SEE ANYTHING AND
SO OFTEN COURAGE YOU TOO WHEN-
WHEN YOU COME BACK UP PROVIDE
US WITH A AND ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO. AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PROVIDE US WITH A PLAN FOR HOW
WE WILL GET TO A PLACE WHERE
ALL OF THE- GAPS ARE. ARE MADE
UP AND FUNDED THAT'S WHAT'S
MISSING- I DON'T EXPECT YOU TO
PROVIDE THAT TO US HERE TODAY I
WOULD HAVE LIKED FOR IT TO HAVE
BEEN HERE TODAY BUT- I WOULD
LIKE TO- SUGGESTED IT'S GOING
TO BE VERY IMPORTANT TO US FOR
US TO TALK ABOUT THIS NOT- NEXT
SESSION OR- YOU KNOW AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE. I DON'T
LOOK I'VE I'VE ONLY GOT A
COUPLE YEARS LEFT HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE I DON'T WANT MY
SUCCESSORS TO BE SCRATCHING
THEIR HEADS AND SAYING WELL YOU
GOT THIS REPORT BACK AND- YOU
KNOW TWENTY TWENTY ONE- AND THE
VERY CLEARLY REQUIRED YOU TO BE
THINKING ABOUT NEW FUNDING
SOURCES AND- I FOUND THAT
REPORT ON MY SHELF FOR SCOUT
BUNCH OF DUST ON IT NOTHING
EVER. YOU KNOW NOTHING EVER
TRANSPIRED NONE OF US WANT O
BE IN THAT POSITION AND SOLID
ASK YOU TO PAY PARTICULAR
ATTENTION TO THAT TO- WHEN-
NEXT WE MAY- AND THE- I ONE
WHICH IS WHERE. THE ONLY ONE
WHO'S- A GRAB THE MIKE HERE-
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY YES MISTER BOND. LOOK
SPEAKING PERSONALLY I. I FEEL
SIMILARLY I HAVE BEEN DIRECTOR
NOW THEY TELL ME LONGER THAN
ANYONE HAS EVER BEEN DIRECTOR
OF THIS DEPARTMENT. AND I
BELIEVE VERY MUCH JANET. AND
I'VE ENJOYED WORKING WITH THE
U. AS LEADERS IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE. I CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
THIS INSTITUTION I THINK IT'S
ESSENTIAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE. HERE'S THE CONUNDRUM.
FRANKLY THE DEPARTMENT CAN'T
FEED ITSELF OUT OF THIS
CHALLENGE NO INDIVIDUAL SECTOR
COULD CARRY SUCH A FEE LOAD.
AND THE GENERAL FUND ITSELF IS.
A VERY IMPORTANT FUND FOR SO
MANY PURPOSES ACROSS GOVERNMENT.
AND. IT COMES DOWN TO WHAT
MIGHT BE AN ADDITIVE
SUSTAINABLE PERMANENT FUND
SOURCE. TO ANSWER MR BENNETT'S
QUESTION EARLIER ONE OF THE
THINGS WE SEE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION SPECIES CONSERVATION
THAT'S A GREAT NEED AS OUR
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT PROGRAM.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS YOU ALL
KNOW IN FRONT OF YOU IS A
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE THIRTY
POSITIONS AND- ABOUT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S ONGOING
FUNDING THAT'S PERMANENT
RESPONSIBILITY AND TODAY GIVEN
COVERT AND OTHER THINGS ONE OF
THE APPROACHES FOR THIS CURRENT
BUDGET WAS TO FOCUS IN ON ONE
TIME. CHAIR I'M COGNIZANT THAT
MICELLAR IS IN THE L. A.
RECOMMENDS I COME BACK IN MAY
WITH CONCRETE SOLUTIONS FOR THE
LONG TERM AND I HOPE TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT SO YOUR WORDS VERY
MUCH. RESONATE WITH ME THEY
MATTER AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
DIRECTION. THANK YOU- DIRECTOR
ART ARE TIMES- HERE HAVE
ROUGHLY COINCIDED WITH ONE
OTHER- AND- HI THERE ARE VERY
FEW LEADERS IN THE STATE FOR
WHOM I HAVE MORE RESPECT THAN
YOU AND- I THINK YOU KNOW- THAT
WE'VE DEVELOPED A VERY POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP AND SO IT IS. IN
THAT SPIRIT THAT I FEEL-
PERHAPS A LITTLE BIT FREER
WITHOUT MY COMMENTARY THAN I
MIGHT OTHERWISE WOULD BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THE PLACE
THAT IT COMES FROM- WE WANT
YOUR DEPARTMENT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH ALL OF THE VERY
IMPORTANT GOALS THAT THE THAT
WE HAVE FOR IT- AND WE JUST.
OVER THE YEARS THIS IS NOTHING
NEW OVER THE YEARS HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET THERE AND- I
THINK THIS IS AN INFLECTION
POINT IT'S A TIME WHERE WE ARE-
OKAY YOU KNOW THINGS ARE TOUGH
IN THE STATE- BUT WE ALSO HAVE
THE INFORMATION THAT WE NEED-
AND WE CAN THINK THIS THROUGH.
AND COME UP WITH A PLAN THAT
GETS IMPLEMENTED AND THE SOLVE
MOST IF NOT ALL OF THOSE
STRUCTURAL. ISSUES- SO. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU AGAIN.
YES AND WITHOUT- A LESSER A
COMMENTS- WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE FOR. MISTER CHAIR RACHEL
IT WAS FROM LA- SOME VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS ON THE- DID WE PASS
YOU BY MS HOLLERS AND SORRY.
THE GREAT. RIGHT AWAY. COMMENTS
ON FIRST AROUND THE- PACKED WE
IT'S REASONABLE THE DEPARTMENT
IS PROVIDED THE JUSTIFICATION
FOR EACH OF THE EXPENDITURES
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S THE
ONLY APPROACH THAT YOU COULD
TAKE YOU COULD TAKE A
DIFFERENT- MIX OF ACTIVITIES
THAT AREN'T PROPOSED INCLUDING
SOME THAT MIGHT FOCUS MORE
DIRECTLY ON THE SPECIES AND
HABITAT CONSERVATION AREA YOU
CAN ALSO EVEN PICK WITHIN THE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE PROPOSED IN
PLACE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
EMPHASIS ON DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES FOR EXAMPLE I DID
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE FUNDING
TO THE VEGETATION MAPPING WHICH
REALLY DOES GET SPECIFICALLY AT
THAT SPECIES HABITAT
CONSERVATION ACTIVITY. UNLESS
IN ANOTHER AREA OF THE SECOND
COMMENT AROUND THE SMALLEST
PIECE OF THE PACKAGE THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FOR
FISHING AND HUNTING LICENSE
MODERNIZATION SEEMS LIKE A
WORTHWHILE ACTIVITY BUT IT ALSO
SEEMS LIKE AN ACTIVITY THAT
COULD VERY JUSTIFIABLY BE
FUNDED BY FEES FROM HUNTERS AND
ANGLERS SINCE THEY ARE THE
PRIMARY BENEFICIARIES OF THOSE
ACTIVITIES SO- WE RECOMMEND YOU
MIGHT WANT TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO GO BACK AND LOOK
AND SEE IF THERE IS OTHER FEE
REVENUE THAT COULD BE USED IN
LIEU OF GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THAT ACTIVITY OR AT LEAST PART
OF THAT ACTIVITY- IF IT'S
SOMETHING YOU WANTED TO ADOPT
BEFORE THE END OF THE- BUDGET.
DISCUSSIONS AND THEN FINALLY A
THIRD POINT IS REALLY WHAT WHAT
THE FOCUS OF THE DISCUSSION HAS
BEEN ALREADY REALLY ENCOURAGING
THIS BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT IS THE SYSTEM OF ALL I'M
GOING PLAN AND WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION GOING TO BRING
FORTH SO SUGGESTING MAYBE IN
SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS- BECOME
PARK WITH A PLAN FOR HOW
THEY'VE DONE SUCH A GREAT JOB
DEFINING THE PROBLEMS IN THIS-
THAT SERVICE BIG BUDGET REPORT.
SO WHAT ARE THE NEXT STEPS.
THANK THE YOU VERY MUCH. A
AGAIN FOR A- NOT- CALLING ON
YOU. I MUST BE A LITTLE BIT
RUSTY. AND I HAVE TO SAY THIS
FORMAT- OF. YOU ALL ON VIDEO. I
SEE YOU ALL ON VIDEO- NOT MY
FAVORITE. FOR- BUT I'LL GET YOU
RIGHT HERE AT THE- YEP. THE
THIRD DRIVER NUMBER THIRTY I
GOVERNOR PART OF FINANCE I JUST
IF I CAN MAKE A COUPLE OF JUST
A BRIEF COMMENT AS WELL HAPPY
AND CLOAK. YES WE KNOW THIS
PROPOSAL DOES MAXIMIZE THE USE
OF ONE TIME THE GENERAL FUND
THE AS THE DIRECTOR DID MENTION
TO HELP SUPPORT TECHNOLOGY
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT EQUIPMENT I
REALLY. I'D YOU KNOW MORE
PARTITION FEES AND ACTIVE WAYS
OF- YOU'RE DOING CORRECTIVE
NEEDS WITHIN EXISTING. STAFF
RESOURCE LEVELS AND REALLY DO
HELP TO STAR ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE GAPS WE DON'T THINK
KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS. A LOT
OF QUESTIONS ON THE ON GOING-
FUNDING AND AN ADDITIONAL YOUR
AVAILABLE FUNDING SOURCES AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
WE ARE CONTINUING TO LOOK INTO
WHILE ALSO LOOKING INTO WAYS
TO. CONTINUE MAXIMIZING
EXISTING RESOURCES WHICH YOU
KNOW WHAT WILL. THE- KIND AN
APPROACH IT ALSO HIGHLIGHTED IN
THE REPORT PROVIDED BY THE
DIRECTOR- YOU KNOW ONE THING I
WOULD LIKE NO TWO IS. YOU KNOW
COUPLE YEARS AGO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN THE THIRD BIG
BUDGET REPORT WAS IT WAS
MANDATED BOB YOU KNOW WE HAD
PROVIDED SOME LIMITED TERM
FUNDING THAT WAS SET TO EXPIRE
THIS YEAR. AND LAST YEAR WE
ACTUALLY PERMANENTLY EXTENDED
THE TWENTY THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND WHICH IS
KIND OF ANOTHER ONGOING
INVESTMENT GIVEN THE INITIAL
DATA WE HAD LAST YEAR HER
OBSERVERS BASED BUDGET WE
ALREADY KIND OF MADE A YOU KNOW
INITIAL ONGOING INVESTMENT.
THIS ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
INVESTMENT YOU KNOW CONTINUES
TO HELP ADDRESS THAT GAP- AND
ACKNOWLEDGING WE WILL CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE- THE TABLE FUNDING
ISSUE- YOU KNOW. WHATEVER YOU
TAKE YOUR REQUEST BACK ON ON B.
YOU KNOW ALTERNATIVE THIS OUT
YOU KNOW WHAT THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS AT THIS POINT NOT SURE
IF WE COMMIT TO HAVING
EVERYTHING YOU KNOW WE'RE YOU
KNOW FINE TUNED AND READY FOR
THAT BUT. WE'LL DEFINITELY TAKE
YOUR REQUEST BACK. THANK YOU-
THAT SOUNDS A LITTLE BIT
PASSIVE. TO ME- I'D JUST LIKE
TO SAY. YOU GUYS NEED TO HELP
THE US DEPARTMENT. OF A BECOME
FULLY FUNDED AND ET ON ITS
FEET. SO THAT IT CAN FULLY
CARRY OUT ITS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT MISSION FOR THE
STATE. I CAN'T TO EMPHASIZE HOW
STRONGLY I FEEL ABOUT THAT I
THINK OF THE SUB COMMITTEE
JOINS ME IN THAT REGARD. AND
I'D JUST LIKE TO- ENCOURAGE YOU
AS- AS MUCH AS I CAN TO NOT
THINK ABOUT THIS. AS SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE PUT OFF INTO THE
FUTURE BUT THAT WE NEED TO.
ADDRESS IN A FAR MORE
SUBSTANTIVE MANNER THAN- AT
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL. DOES AT
THE PRESENT TIME. THANK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR IS- SIGMA THE
US A STABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KARLEY FAMOUS I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND I AM HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL- THAT IS
REQUESTING THAT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND ANOTHER
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND IN THE BUDGET
YEAR- TO SUPPORT OUR GRANT
PROGRAM- THAT CAN ENABLE.
PROJECTS AND- IMPLEMENTATION OF
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT PLANS- FROM THE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
GROUNDWATER BASINS- YOU MAY
RECALL THAT- SIGMAR REQUIRED
THESE BASINS THAT HAVE A LEGACY
OVER OVER DRAFTED NOT THAT TO
THAT CATEGORY OF A CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED. TO PROVIDE THEIR
PLANS TO THE DEPARTMENT- IN
JANUARY OF- THE PREVIOUS- THIS
YEAR AND WE NOW HAVE TO HEAR TO
ABOUT FOR PLANS WERE THAT THE
VALUATION ON- THOSE.
GROUNDWATER AGENCIES ARE
IMPLEMENTING THOSE PLANS. SO
THE REQUESTED TO PROVIDE
FUNDING- FOR A VARIETY OF
ACTIVITIES THAT COULD INCLUDE
THE CONSTRUCTION OF PROJECTS
THAT WILL INCREASE WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY THE PLANNING AND
DESIGN OF THOSE PROJECTS THOSE
CAN INCLUDE THINGS LIKE THE
STORM WATER CAPTURE GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE A RECYCLED WATER.
LOCAL CONVEYANCE- TO MOVE WATER
FROM POINT A TO POINT B. ALSO
STUDIES THAT WILL ADDRESS-
REALLY IMPORTANT DATA GAPS THAT
ARE THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
IN THE PLANS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED THUS FAR- AND COULD
INCLUDE THE INSTALLATION OF
MONITORING WELLS- AND OTHER
EFFORTS THAT WILL ADDRESS SOME
OF THE DEFICIENCIES IN THIS
INITIAL ROUND OF. GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS SO I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU ALL MAY HAVE.
QUESTIONS. I JUST ONE FOR ME
AND THAT IS REFLECTED IN THE
STAFF REPORT TO- WHY DOES THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS SO BUT
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT FOR TO BE
AN EARLY ACTION. SURE SO- OUR
LAB JUST FOR REPORTS ON OUR OUR
LAST ROUND OF GRANTS WE HAD
ACCELERATED PROP SIXTY EIGHT
DOLLARS- WE HAD TWENTY SIX
MILLION- AVAILABLE FOR- FOR THE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
GROUNDWATER BASINS WE HAD ABOUT
SEVENTY MILLION- IN PROPOSALS
SO. YOU KNOW YOU CAN YOU CAN DO
THE MATH AND UNDERSTAND THE
DEFICIT BETWEEN AVAILABLE
FUNDING IN NEED- IF WE- GET THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND IN THIS CURRENT
BUDGET YEAR WE ESTIMATE THAT IT
WOULD TAKE US- ABOUT FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS- RATHER FOUR
MONTHS AFTER ITS APPROPRIATION.
TO PUT OUT THE PROJECT
SOLICITATION PROPOSAL AND THAT
PUTS US AT THE END OF THIS YEAR
WHICH COINCIDES WITH OUR FINAL
DECISIONS ON THESE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS AND IT
ENABLES- PARTIES TO START
IMPLEMENTING RIGHT AWAY SO THAT
WOULD PUT US- MISTER CHAIR AND-
A YEAR FROM NOW ESSENTIALLY
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
WHEN THOSE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES WOULD
BE UNDER CONTRACT AND ABLE TO
USE THOSE FUNDS TO START
IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT EXPLANATION. MR
ABOUT. BOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR- THE FIRST THING
THAT I WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT
OUT IS JUST FROM A REGULATORY
STANDPOINT- YOU YOU WILL HAVE
TO BE MONITORING THESE PLANS
AND- WITH THE TWENTY YEAR TIME
HORIZON THAT THEY HAVE TO BRING
THE PLANS AGAIN TO- COMPLIANCE-
I. AM CONCERNED THAT. YOU HAVE
THAT WE HAVE REALISTIC
PROJECTIONS IN TERMS OF NEW
WATER SOURCES AND THIS GRANT
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO DEVELOP NEW WATER
SOURCES UP SO I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT- AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THAT TRY TO
BRIEF US IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE
YOU DOING TO ENSURE BECAUSE
THERE'S TREMENDOUS INCENTIVE
THERE TO HAVE UNREALISTIC
PROPOSALS. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO ANY
CUTBACKS YOU CAN JUST SAY HEY
YEAH WE'RE OVER DRAFTING NOW
BUT WE'RE GONNA GET ALL THIS
NEW WATER AND IN A WHILE AND SO
WE ARE DOING. WHAT WILL THE
DEPARTMENT BE DOING AND IT IS
THERE SHOULD THERE BE SOME SOME
FUNDING SET ASIDE TO MAKE SURE-
THAT WERE BEING REALISTIC OR
HAVE THE RIGHT KIND OF
PROFESSIONAL ANALYSIS UP TO BE
REALISTIC. THE SECOND THING IS
SOME OF THESE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES ARE
USING WATER MARKETS AND WILL
THE DEPARTMENT BE PROVIDING ANY
GUIDANCE TO MAKE SURE WATER
MARKETS ARE NOT BEING USED- TO
DISADVANTAGE- SOME COMMUNITIES
DOMESTIC WELL OWNERS SIX CENTER
OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE
SHALLOWER WELLS- BOOK MY
BIGGEST QUESTION IS. JUST THE
WHOLE ISSUE WE'VE HAD SOME SOME
STARK- AND A TRAGIC EXAMPLES OF
DRINKING WATER- AND THIS
ADVANCE COMMUNITIES REALLY
BEING PUT AT GREAT
DISADVANTAGE- BECAUSE THEIR
WELLS WENT DRY WALL PEOPLE WERE
OVER DRAFTING NOT VERY FAR
AWAY- IS IT APPROPRIATE- AND MY
QUESTION IS BOTH FOR DEPARTMENT
WATER RESOURCES. AND THE STATE
WATER. CONTROL BOARD THERE ARE
NEXT. HERE ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
PROTECTING THOSE PRECIOUS
DRINKING WATER SOURCES- IN THIS
GROUND LARGEST INABILITY
PLANNING PROCESS- IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND DO YOU HAVE ANY
PLANS FOR ENGAGING.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE- STRONG
REPRESENTATION AT THE TABLE-
BOTH IN THE SAID THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE PLANS BUT
THAT THE PLANS AND PERHAPS YOU
HAVE SOME INCENTIVES IN THE-
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT YOU
ASK FOR- PLANS THAT TAKE INTO
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION OR MAKE
SPECIAL EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
DRINKING WATER FOR THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THOSE ARE MY QUESTIONS TO SORT
OF IN A GENERAL BROUGHT IT THE
GENERAL CATION I KNOW YOU WON'T
BE ABLE TO ANSWER ALL THOSE
RIGHT NOW BUT THOSE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE FOR THE-
FOR THE DEPARTMENT THANK YOU.
SO CERTAINLY. MAYBE I'LL TAKE.
YOUR LAST QUESTION FIRST- WE
ARE VERY AWARE OF- THE
HEIGHTENED CONCERNS IN THE VERY
JUSTIFIABLE CONCERNS. THAT- THE
GROUNDWATER PLANS WILL FURTHER
EXACERBATE DRINKING WATER
QUALITY- PARTICULARLY FOR
DOMESTIC WELLS AND IN
PARTICULAR- IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- THE DEPARTMENT IS
COORDINATING BEING IN A VERY
INTENSIVE WAY AROUND OUR PLAN
REVIEW AND- HOW- THESE PLANS
FROM CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
BASINS INTERFACED WITH THE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER-
INITIATIVE TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE PUTTING UNDUE BURDEN ON
THAT PROGRAM. AND THAT ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN
THE CONTEXT OF SIX MONTHS AS IT
RELATES TO OUR DOMESTIC WELLS
AS ONE OF SEVERAL BENEFICIAL
USES ARE ARE ADDRESSED SO-
THERE ARE REALLY SPECIFIC WAYS
IN WHICH THE DEPARTMENT AND ITS
REVIEW OF. THE PLANS AND ITS
ABILITY TO ESTABLISH CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS AND- INCENTIVIZE AND
WORK WITH THE LOCAL GSA'S TO-
ENABLE THEM TO DO A BETTER JOB
AND WORKING WITH DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. IN PARTICULAR-
PART OF THOSE CAN THAT ARE
RELIANT ON DOMESTIC WELLS I
THINK THE OTHER PIECE OF IT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS WE'RE
STARTING TO UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THE LIMITATIONS OF THE DATA.
THAT IS AVAILABLE AND WE ARE
GONNA HAVE TO MAKE. IMPORTANT
IMPROVEMENTS IN THAT DATA AND
THE AVAILABILITY OF THAT DATA.
WHICH WE ALREADY WHICH WE
ALREADY ARE WHICH IS GOOD NEWS
BUT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AS MUCH AS IMPLEMENTED A
TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION ON THE
ROLE OF THE DEPARTMENT- IS YOU
KNOW ONCE PLANS ARE- DEEMED
ADEQUATE OR- DEEMED INADEQUATE
AND THAT- MOVES THE PLAN INTO
THE JURISDICTION OF THE WATER
BOARD- FOR RESOLUTION BUT- FOR
PLANS THAT ARE ADEQUATE. THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT ANNUAL
REPORTS- BUT THEN EVERY FIVE
YEARS IS A FULL SCALE REVIEW OF
THOSE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
PLANS SO THOSE PLANS. THAT ARE-
BUT LEE- OVERLY ROSY ABOUT THE
AVAILABILITY OF ADDITIONAL
WATER- WE WILL BE LOOKING FOR
ALSO IN THOSE PLANS AND
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF IF THAT
WATER DOES NOT BECOME AVAILABLE
WHAT ARE THEIR DEMAND
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES TO- TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR PLAN
WILL RESULT IN SUSTAINABILITY
AT THE END OF THE- TWENTY YEAR
PERIOD. AS A GENERAL MATTER-
YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
SUPPORT. AS MANY COMMUNITY USES
AS ALL THE BENEFICIAL USES AS
AS POSSIBLE IN THESE AREAS WITH
A HEALTHY GROUNDWATER BASINS SO
I THINK IT'S NATURAL AS YOU
POINT OUT THAT- A LOT OF THESE
PLANS YOU KNOW THEIR FIRST STEP
IS TO WELL LET'S LOOK AND SEE
WHAT ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS WE
CAN MAKE. AND PROJECTS THAT
WOULD IMPROVE THE WATER
SUPPLIES COMING INTO THESE
AREAS BUT WE DON'T KNOW IF
WE'RE WE'RE VERY MUCH
CHALLENGED BY RESOURCE SCARCITY
ISSUE SO WHAT PASSED THE COME
IN AND- IN TANDEM WITH THAT ARE
REALLY CREDIBLE PLANS TO-
MANAGE DEMAND- MORE FULLY SO
THAT- AS THE PLAN IS
IMPLEMENTED OVER THE NEXT
TWENTY YEARS. THERE'S
TRANSPARENCY AND CLARITY ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET TO A
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER. SOURCE
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA. IT IT IF
YOU COULD INSTALL UP IN THAT IS
JUST TO EMPHASIZE OF THE
TREMENDOUS OF IMPORTANCE OF
YOUR ROLE IN. KEEPING THOSE
PLANS CREDIBLE YOU TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHETHER THE PLAN IS
ADEQUATE OR NOT THAT'S THE
THAT'S REALLY WANTS A PLAN GETS
IDENTIFIED IS NOT ADEQUATE
THAT'S- A LOT OF THINGS CAN
HAPPEN BUT- TO MAKE SURE THE-
PLANS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED AS
ADEQUATE TRULY ARE ADEQUATE IS.
A RESPONSIBILITY THAT NOBODY
ELSE IN THE IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NO NO INTEREST GROUP
OR ANYBODY ELSE WILL BE ABLE TO
DO- AND IT'S ESSENTIAL AND
THERE. WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S TREMENDOUS
PRESSURE ON THE OTHER SIDE TO
TRY TO DE IDENTIFY THESE PLANS
IS ADEQUATE- AND YOU ARE REALLY
THERE THE TRUE REPRESENTATIVE
THE ONLY REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
PEOPLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S BALANCE IN THAT
EVALUATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME MR FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- IT I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION I
HAVE I KNOW THAT SIGMA
CERTAINLY ACT A BIG CONCERN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- I ALSO WANTED
TO GET YOUR INPUT AND TAKE ON
AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
FOCUS ON THE DEMAND SIDE BUT
THEN OF COURSE ONE OF FOCUS ON
THE SUPPLY SIDE AS WELL IN
TERMS OF- ADEQUATE WATER
SUPPLIES AND I JUST WANTED TO
GET YOUR TAKE ON. THAT A LOT OF
THESE A LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE-
FIVE WAYS THAT REQUIRE US TO
ADDRESS AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH WAS AND THE ITEMS ARE
HEARD BUT THEN. ALSO IN IN LOOK
UP LARGER WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS- THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES NEED TO TAKE THAT
MAY NOT BE DONE THE AND- IN A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. AND THAT
MAY GET A LOT OF THESE
COMMITTEES TO SUSTAINABILITY.
SO I GUESS MAYBE YOU CAN
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT I'M
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE LOOKING.
AT THESE ISSUES THROUGH A STRAW
IN SILOS HOW DID PADDOCK HOW DO
YOU GUYS VIEW. CIGNA THROUGH
THE NEED FOR. LARGER WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE STORAGE PROJECTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT'S A GREAT.
IT IS INTEGRATING OUR WATER
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT NEEDS WITH
CIGNA IS- THE GOVERNOR'S WATER
RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO. AND YOU
MENTIONED A COUPLE OF THINGS
YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE- THE STATE
WATER PROJECT FOR EXAMPLE PLAYS
A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
PROVIDING SURFACE WATER TO
COMMUNITIES THAT- COULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR RECHARGE. THE
WATER TRANSFER PROGRAM THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- BENNETT.
RAISED AS WELL- T. W. R. IS-
WORKING ON A REALLY IMPORTANT
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
TRANSPARENCY OF. THE WATER
TRANSFER PROGRAM SO THAT WE
CAN- GET THROUGH THEM THIS THIS
YEAR IS A DRY HERE AND WE'RE
ANTICIPATING A VERY ACTIVE
WATER TRANSFER MARKET WHICH
WOULD BE TYPICAL- BUT WE ARE-
UNDERWEIGHT AND EXPANDING THE
TRANSFER. MARKET AS IT RELATES
TO THE STATE WATER PROJECT- WE
DO HAVE WE HAVE RECENTLY
AMENDED OUR STATE WATER. ROGIC
CONTRACTS THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
LONGER TERM TRANSFERS AND- A
HUGE BENEFIT OF THAT IS HOW
THAT WORKS- WITH SOME OF THE-
WATER RECHARGING NEEDS
PARTICULARLY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO THAT'S THAT'S JUST
ONE EXAMPLE THERE'S OTHER
ELEMENTS WITHIN THE WATER
RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO- THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION- IS
WORKING ON- STUDYING. WHAT WE
CALL REGIONAL CONVEYANCE SO
WHAT WHAT ARE THE ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS IN
PARTICULAR REGIONS THAT WOULD.
IN WORKING WITH A TRANSFER
PROGRAM AND WORKING WITH OTHER
BROADER BACKBONE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS HELP US MOVE WATER
TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE SO
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT ALTHOUGH IT
THESE THINGS NEED TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER. AND I CAN'T EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH- YOU KNOW THE BIG
CHALLENGE THAT I THINK YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALL ACUTELY AWARE US. IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THIS KIND OF A
RESOURCE SCARCITY ISSUE. AS YOU
KNOW SOME OF THESE SOME OF
THESE CONDITIONS HAVE BEEN
DECADES IN THE MAKING AND-
WHAT'S GOING TO BE ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL IS HOW WELL WE
IMPLEMENT THESE PLANS- AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS. FULLY COMMITTED
TO THAT THERE'S A LOT OF- I
WOULD SAY GENERAL ANXIETY ABOUT
YOU KNOW THE ADEQUACY
DETERMINATION AND THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT DECISION
THAT THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO
MAKE IT NEEDS TO BE DECISIONS
THAT ARE- OF THE HIGHEST DEGREE
OF TECHNICAL INTEGRITY- THAT
MEET THE SPIRIT OF THE LAW. BUT
ULTIMATELY. WE REALLY ROLL UP
OUR SLEEVES AND IMPLEMENT THESE
PLANS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO DRIVE A
LOT OF IMPORTANT DECISIONS ON
HOW WE'RE MANAGING THIS WATER
RESOURCE IN CALIFORNIA. AND IT
CERTAINLY NEEDS TO SUPPORT-
LOCAL ECONOMIES AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND ENSURE THAT OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER AND THIS
CAN REALLY BE A TOOL TO HELP
US. ADDRESS SOME OF THE EQUITY
ISSUES THAT HAVE PLAGUED THAT-
YOU KNOW PLAYED TO THESE
COMMUNITIES BUT AGAIN ONE OF
THE ANOTHER BENEFICIAL USE- AS-
REQUIRED IN THE LAW IS ON THESE
GROUNDWATER DEPENDENT
ECOSYSTEMS SO THERE'S ALSO AN
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPONENT. SO
IMPLEMENT. IN MANY WAYS IS
GETTING IMPLEMENTATION THE
FOUNDATIONS OF IMPLEMENTATION
SET UP APPROPRIATELY SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT ALL PARTS OF
THE COMMUNITY ARE ENGAGED AND
WE CAN BE SURE THAT- THERE IS A
TRANSPARENT. AND PUBLIC WAY OF
INTERACTING AS SOME OF OUR
INITIAL ASSUMPTIONS AND YOU
KNOW TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS THOSE ASSUMPTIONS
PROVE TO BE TRUE OR NOT TRUE-
THERE IS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THERE IS- AN ABILITY TO MOVE TO
OTHER- PLANS FOR IMPLEMENTATION
THAT CAN ENSURE THAT ALL
BENEFICIAL USES ARE PROTECTED.
AND THAT THE SPACE AND THE
CHIEF SUSTAINABILITY BY TWENTY
FORTY. HI APPRECIATE THAT I
GUESS LANKER TO THE OF THE
BUILD IN SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
ALIGN THE TIME LINES TOGETHER
TO CREATE SOME SYNERGY.
COORDINATE WITH THE GSA'S THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS THE
WATER AGENCIES NOTED SOMETHING
A LOT OF COMMITTEES BOTH MEN
CERTAINLY ALL COMMITTEES ARE
UNIQUE. BUT MOST COMMITTEES MAY
NEED ADDITIONAL PIPELINES THEY
MADE A NEED FOR CONVEYANCERS
STUDIES AND WILL AND SURFACED
ORDER OR UNDERGROUND STORAGE
AND OF THOSE PROJECTS. TAKE A
LONG TIME WITH WITH NEEDED
RESOURCES AND SO IF THAT'S THE
GOAL IF THOSE PROJECTS ARE
NEEDED FOR SUSTAINABILITY BUT
THEY'RE BEING. HARMED OR
PUNISHED ON THE ON THE FRONT
AND WENT IN IN TERMS OF BUT
THEY KNOW THEY KNOWLEDGE
AFFECTING NEED THOSE
INVESTMENTS IN THE LONG RUN-
JUST TO ALIGN THOSE TIMELINES.
AND PHILANDO SCHOOL. A LOT OF.
I THINK ALL COMMITTEES TO GET
THERE BUT SOME. WHAT WE NEED TO
BE DONE AND WHAT CAN BE
IMMEDIATELY DON'T ALIGN AND SO
AS LONG AS THERE'S FLEXIBILITY-
AND WORKING TOGETHER IN
COORDINATION WITH. THE STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS GSA'S I THINK
THAT THAT'S THE PATH FORWARD
NOT SOME RIGID- ABIDETH BY SOME
CALENDAR. APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU CERTAINLY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR A PARTY WE HAVE-
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM L.
A. O. OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YES THANK YOU AGAIN REGIONALLY
LIVES WITH THE L. A. M. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS
JUSTIFIED AND MEETS AN
IMPORTANT STATE NEED AND STATE
PRIORITY THESE ARE THE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
IN PARTICULAR. OF THE DOUBLE
BURDEN OF BOTH THE GREATEST
IMBALANCE AND THE MOST
EXPEDITED TIMELINES. WE DO NOT
FIND- THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
GVEN A COMPELLING RATIONALE
FOR EARLY ACTION I THINK YOU'LL
HEAR A COMMON THEME FROM US
OVER THE NEXT FEW WEEKSOF
HEARINGS THAT WE THINK THERE'S
A PRETTY HIGH BAR- THAT THE
STATION MUST MEET IN ORDER TO
JUSTIFY PUTTING OUT MANY EARLY-
IT REALLY DOES LIMIT THE
LEGISLATURE'S. FLEXIBILITY
PARTICULARLY AROUND GENERAL
FUND INTENDED JUNE YOU'VE
ALREADY TAKEN SOME GENERAL FUND
OFF THE TABLE THROUGH EARLY
APPROPRIATIONS. SO OUR
RECOMMENDATION HERE WOULD BE TO
PUT THE FULL SIXTY MILLION OUT
OR CONSIDER THE FULL SIXTY
MILLION AS PART OF THE FULL
BUDGET PACKAGE RATHER THAN-
SENDING HALF OF IT OUT EARLY.
YOU KNOW WHILE WHILE IT MAY BE
NICE TO HAVE RENDON AN INITIAL
GRANT ROUND A FEW MONTHS
CERTAINLY THAT PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT FUNDING FOR THIS IS
ACTUALLY NOT EVEN GOING TO BE
AWARDED INTEL MAY. SO WE THINK
THAT- SENDING THE WHOLE FUNDING
OUT WITH NOT ONLY BE EASIER
ADMINISTRATIVELY BUT ALSO
PRESERVE. SOME OF THE
LEGISLATURE SPECS ABILITY.
THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SURE BRENT BEAUDOIN
FINANCE I WOULD GO DOWN DID IT
AS IT RELATES TO THE THIRTY
MILLION IN IN BING PROPOSED IN
CURRENT YEAR- AGAIN. JUST
ALIGNING THIS PROPOSAL WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BROADER
EFFORTS REALLY TRY TO PROVIDE
TARGETED TO MEET THE TARGET TO
MEET IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR AREAS
THAT ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. BY THE PANDEMIC AND
REALLY TRYING TO SUPPORT
EQUITABLE BROAD BASED RECOVERY
AND SO WITH THIS IN IMMEDIATE
INVESTMENT WOULD BE ABLE TO.
ACCELERATE ECONOMIC STIMULUS
PRIMARILY A CENTRAL VALLEY AND
REALLY PROVIDE THAT CRUCIAL
SUPPORTS IT IS PRETTY CLEAR.
SINCE I'M PROVIDING THIS EARLY
ACTION THIS FUNDING AS AS EARLY
IN THE CURRENT- WILL WILL ALLOW
W. ARE TO BEGIN THE
SOLICITATION PROCESS WORK THIS
PROJECT EARLIER WHICH WOULD
HELP PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF.
TO THOSE IMPACTED. THANK YOU
FOR THAT I. FOR SURE THAT- WITH
THAT WILL MOVE ON TO A FIVE.
RELATING TO URBAN FLOOD RISK
REDUCTION. THIS REQUEST IS A
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROPOSAL TO
SUPPORT- THE STATE COST SHARE
REQUIREMENT AND- WHAT'S CALLED
THE AMERICAN RIVER COMMON
FEATURES PROJECT IT'S A
CRITICAL FLOOD RISK REDUCTION
PROJECT THAT IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED BY THE US ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS- THIS
REQUEST WILL SUPPORT A PROJECT
PAYMENTS TO THE CORE. REAL
ESTATE ACQUISITION A UTILITY
RELOCATIONS AND CONTRACT WORK
THAT'S NEEDED TO MEET THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OUT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS OUTLINED IN A
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT WITH THE
COURT- AS WELL AS FUNDING FOR
EXISTING D. W. R. STAFF IN
FISCAL YEAR- TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO THAT'S REQUIREDTO MEET THE
NEEDS OF ALL THESE ACCELERATED
PROJECT SCHEDULES- WE ARE
REQUESTING- SIXTY SEVEN MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND AT. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED FOURTEEN
MILLION- AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY ONE AND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND THEN
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION AND-
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THIS
LEVERAGES ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS A FEDERAL
EMERGENCY SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
AND TOTAL THE AMERICAN RIVER
COMMON FEATURES PROJECT- PER
TAX- MORE THAN HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE AND FIFTY MUCH FIFTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. WORTH OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ASSETS. SO
BE HAPPY TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FACING NONE
THAT WE HAVE A REPORT FROM L.
A. O. N. DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
AGAIN RACHEL ENTERS WITH THE L.
A. O. JUST TO KNOW THAT WELL
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND- COMMITMENT OVER THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS THAT LEVERAGES A
VERY SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING AND WOOD. AB
HELPED TO COMPLETE A VERY LARGE
I HAVE A PROJECT IN IN OUR
REGION NEAR THE CAPITAL REGION
THAT WILL REALLY INCREASE
PUBLIC SAFETY SO WE RECOMMEND
ADOPTION. THANK YOU. WHAT THAT
SILENCE I'M GOING TO ASSUME THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
NOTHING TO ADD- BUT- LOOKING
FURTHER CARE THANK YOU HI THANK
YOU- I WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
ITEM BUT- NOTING THAT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION HERE IS THAT IN
THE ABSENCE OF- A QUESTIONS. OR
PUBLIC INPUT THAT- STAFF NEEDS
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION-
THAT. BOTH THIS AND TO THE
FOLLOWING ISSUE NUMBER SIX B.
PLACED ON THE VOTE ONLY ONLY
CALENDAR WHEN WE COME BACK TO
THESE ISSUES AT A FUTURE
MEETING- AND DOES SO- THAT
TAKES US THROUGH OUR LAST ISSUE
OF THE DAY ISSUE. SIX ONE TIME
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ALLOCATIONS. THE THIRD DRIVER
WITH A PET AND THOUGHT I'LL
TAKE THE PHONE OFF AND I KNOW I
HAVE A FEW OTHER- COLLEAGUES
FROM APART WATER RESOURCES PART
THE AND CAL PART BECAUSE
SOMEBODY TOLD AS WELL SO THE
BUDGET DOES INCLUDE A HUNDRED
OF FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. TO THE BOARD SOME
CRITICAL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS ACROSS THREE DEPARTMENTS-
THE CALIFORNIA. ALL KNOW THAT
THIS IS PART OF A- BROADER-
COMPREHENSIVE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PACKAGE- ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION- ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND ACROSS ELEVEN
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE. THE VETERANS WILL
HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CRITICAL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG- HAVE PRODUCED SOME-
YOU KNOW. HAVE YOUR COST AND
THEN ALSO JUST SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BROADER
CLIMBERS IN THE EFFORTS- YOU
PARTICULAR WITH- OTHER NEED TO
BE OUR ALLOCATION- PROPERTY FOR
MAINTENANCE. IT'S AND AGAIN WE
REPRESENT ART WHO GETS TO SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAILS IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU AND-
BEFORE ANYBODY ELSE- LETS ME
TO- WE DO HAVE ONE MORE ISSUE-
ISSUE SEVEN HUNDRED SOMETHING
SOMEHOW I MISSED THE OPEN. GET
NERVOUS- YEAH THE THIRD JUST ME.
DO WE HAVE A REPORTER FROM-
ANYONE ELSE ON THIS ISSUE.
RETAILERS ALEJO AS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT MANY YEARS YEARS IN
RECENT YEARS THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ADDRESSING THE
STATE'S DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG IS A REALLY GOOD USE OF
ONE TIME MONEY WHEN YOU HAVE
ONE TEN RESOURCES AVAILABLE.
ALL THREE OF THESE DEPARTMENTS
DO HAVE EXTENSIVE BACKLOG OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND ALL
THREE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DESCRIBE- HOW THEY WOULD
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS HOW THEY
WOULD SELECT PROJECTS SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL FULL. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER REPORTS. MY ONLY
COMMENT ON THIS IS THAT I WAS
SO SURPRISED TO LEARN- JUST HOW
EXTENSIVE THE- A DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUES ARE AND SOME
OF THESE DEPARTMENTS AND THAT'S
NOT GOOD FOR THE STATE OR OR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT SO- AN ISSUE
THAT WE SHOULD- PROBABLY FOCUS
WILL MORE ATTENTION ON. L. THE
UNLESS THERE'S- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS SIR- WILL MOVE ON TO-
ISSUE SEVEN AND- AND CAREFULLY
LOOKING. TO SAY THAT THERE'S
NOTHING ELSE GOING ON GREW UP
AGAIN FITTED- INTO HIS TWO
SEVEN IS THAT CYCLING THAT
PROGRAM INVESTIGATION AND
CLEANUP MISTER CHAIR YES I DID
HAVE A QUESTION IN REGARDS TO
OF ISSUE SIX- OF WORK WITH A
GROUP OF DEFERRED COSTS WHAT DO
WE HAVE TEN MILLION FOR
CALIFORNIA- INNER HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN. MILLION OR TWO DEFERRALS
IS THERE ANY WAY WE CAN DOUBLE
THAT AMOUNT TO TRY TO HELP
CALIFORNIA HELP WITH THE ISSUE
THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS WITH ALL THE
FIREMEN IT'S JUST A COMMENT
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
BACK THROUGH IT BUT I'D LIKE TO
SEE MORE MONEY GOING TO CAL
FIRE TO. TRY TO CLEAN UP SOME
OF THE FIRES THAT WE'VE HAD
THIS HISTORY THERE THERE
LISTENING AND DOES SO I THINK
THE QUESTION IS- ARE THERE- IS
THERE A PLACE THAT WE CAN LOOK
TO FIND RESOURCES TO- BRING CAL
FIRE MORE CURRENT ON ITS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- ISSUES
AND I WOULD LIKE TO. JOIN IN
SHOULD LOOK AT THAT TO SEE HOW
MUCH MORE WE CAN DO AND- IN
THIS BUDGET. YEAR THANK THANK
YOU MISTER SMITH. I AM NOW ON
TO IF YOU'RE- SEVEN. MORNING
CHAIR MORE KNOWLEDGEABLE
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY. BUT I
WAS WALKING AROUND AND CHAIR OF
THE STATE WATER BOARD AND FOR A
MOMENT THERE I THOUGHT I WAS
GONNA GET OUT OF THE SIDE OF.
GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL AND JUST
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME. YOU
KNOW I REALLY QUIET QUICKLY
REFLECT BACK TO THE COMMENTS
THAT. ARE DIRECTOR NEMETH MADE-
AND THE QUESTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT. AROUND SICK MY
AND COORDINATION AROUND THESE
REALLY. CRITICAL GOALS THAT WE
HAVE THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
HELD WATER RESILIENCY PORTFOLIO
IS REALLY STITCHES TOGETHER-
IT'S THAT THAT IS THE CASE. AND
REALLY THE COORDINATION THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES.
TECHNOLOGY AT CIGNA
IMPLEMENTATION. IS A CONTINUE
ALONG OF IMPLEMENTATION BETWEEN
OUR TWO AGENCIES. AND WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO UNDER THIRTY. THE
GREATEST TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
SEN AND I LEADERSHIP WITH OUR
DEPARTMENTS. TO HELP US.
NAVIGATE WHAT ARE. GOING TO BE.
A DIFFICULT ASSESSMENT NOT EASY
CERTAINLY FOR THE FARM WATER
RESOURCES. BUT THEN AGAIN. WHAT
WE WANT TO BE. A HIS WIDE OPEN
AND UNDERSTANDING HOW WE
ACCOMPLISH THEIR- INCREDIBLE
GOAL OF. ENSURING THAT THE
MILLING CAL. WITH ACCESS TO SAY
ENOUGH FOR WATER ARE CONJOINED
WITH THE CALLS OF SIGMA WHICH
IS INCREDIBLE OVERLAP WITHIN
THE COMMUNITIES THERE IMPACTS
AND THE WAY WE IMPLEMENT OUR
OUR VARIOUS PROGRAMS SO I JUST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THE
DIRECTOR'S LEADERSHIP AND THE
GREAT WORK THAT WE'VEBEEN ABLE
TO DO OVER THE LAST MONTHS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
DISCUSSION WITH THE- WITH THE-
THE LEGISLATURE AROUND AROUND
AT WORK. SO JUST THINKING. I'M
ON HERE ON THOUGH IS ACTUALLY
ON OUR SITE CLEANUP PROGRAM.
AND INVESTMENT INVESTIGATION
AND CLEANUP OUR SITE. CLEANUP
PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE CORE
PROGRAMS AT THE STATE ATER
BOARD. IT IS HOW WE CLEAN UP
WHAT IS A CREDIBLE LEGACY OF
THE DEGRADATION OF OUR WATER
QUALITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT. OTHER
BIG GOALS LIKE SIX MONTHS- AS
WE LOOK AT THE CHALLENGES THE
CLIMATE CHANGE. WE FACE DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE WATER QUALITY
IS. CONTINUING TO BE- WILL BE
EIGHT EIGHT ISSUE WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON. AND IT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
CHALLENGING YOU KNOW IT IS THE
BASIS FOR ALL OF OUR ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY. R. OR ACCESS TO WATER
AND THE QUALITY OF THAT WATER
WHICH IMPACTS LARA BENEFICIAL
USES. AND SO. THE REQUEST HERE
IS FOR A TWENTY ONE PERMANENT
POSITIONS CURRENTLY THE PROGRAM
HAVE SEVENTY FIVE. AND THERE'S
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND OPEN CASES
BUT ONLY ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED THAT ARE ACTIVE BUT
THAT SEVENTY FIVE. MEMBER STAFF
CAN ACTUALLY BE WORKING ON
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- THESE
PROGRAMS THAT VARY IN
COMPLEXITY- AND IN H. I. AN
UNDERSTANDING HERE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE CUT CONTAMINANTS OF
EMERGING CONCERN. SHE PASSED
THAT ARE INCREASING THE
WORKLOAD SO WE'RE SEEING OUT
THERE BUT WE ALSO HAVE HUGE OUR
LEGACY CHALLENGES AROUND. DC PD
BY ONE TWO THREE TCP- YOU KNOW.
VOLATILE I A CO. FROM FROM IN
JUST THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
SO- YOU KNOW THESE THESE THIS
PROGRAM IS SUCH A CORE PROGRAM
WHEN IT COMES TO ACTUALLY
IMPROVING. THE QUALITY OF OUR
WATER RESOURCES BILL SURFACE
AND GROUNDWATER THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND I THINK IT'S A
QUICKLY ALIGNED AS WELL WITH
THE WATER RESILIENCE FOLIO. AND
SO I WOULD JUST SPEAK AND
SUPPORT HERE- YOU KNOW
CURRENTLY THERE IS ABOUT A
BACKLOG OF ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
AND NINETY CASES. OUT THAT IS
DOWN FROM A FEW YEARS AGO UP IN
THAT YOU KNOW YEAH THOUSANDS
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO WORK-
AWAY AT THAT BACKLOG BUT-
ULTIMATELY NEED THE BODIES
ACTUALLY PROCESS. WHAT ARE NOT
BY AND LARGE REIMBURSABLE-
ACTIVITIES OF THESE ARE AGAIN
THAT WE HAVE RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES- THEY'RE THEY'RE OFTEN
VOLUNTARILY TAKEN OUT. BUT WE
NEED THAT THE STAFF OVER ACTION
WERE RECEIVED THE ACTUAL SITE
CLEANUP THE TECHNICAL RESOURCES
TO APPROVE THE BEAT UP PLANS.
AND ACTUALLY. GET GET OUR-
WATERWAYS. IN BETTER SHAPE. SO
ON THANK YOU AND AGAIN. I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE REPORT ANGLER
WE DIDN'T TO PASS OVER YOUR-
BECAUSE OF THE THANK YOU OF THE
WORK YOU DO IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND WE WANT TO PAY
PARTICULAR ATTENTION. TO IT
THERE'S A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
IN THE- STAFF REPORT BUT I
THINK IT KIND OF BOILS DOWN TO-
HOW FAR THESE FUNDS GOING TO
TAKE US WHAT WHAT. MORE WORK
LIES AHEAD WHAT'S GOING TO COST
TO- TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
AND- I HAD TO THE EXTENT
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ARE
IDENTIFIED FOR THE FAST
CONTAMINATION ARE WE GOING TO
BE. LOOKING TO HOLD THOSE
PARTIES RESPONSIBLE DESERVE
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO ACTUALLY
DO THAT. HERE WE THAT YOU KNOW
I WAS REALLY- I WAS LISTENING
QUITE INTENTLY- WITH- DIRECTOR
BONHAMS A REPORT ABOUT THEIR IM
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING AND
ANALYSIS BECAUSE IT MIRRORS A
LOT OF THE PERFORMANCE SPACE-
METRICS AND THAT WE HAVE BUILT
INTO OUR PROGRAM NEARLY TEN
YEARS AGO NOW AND CONTINUE TO
REFINE. THAT SO WE HAVE A LOT
OF WHICH IS TO TELL ALL STATE
THAT CAN HELP US KIND OF A
SCHOOL ABOUT WHAT POTENTIALLY
BUT THE DOLLARS AND THE
POSITIONS YOU KNOW MEAN AND SO
FAR AND SO FAR AS NUMBER
PROJECTS TO BE COMPLETED YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH OF THAT BACKLOG
CAN COME DOWN. WE CAN WILL
CIRCLE BACK WITH SOME OF THAT
DATA I'LL JUST SAY THAT MUCH OF
THAT IS IN HINDSIGHT- IT'S HARD
SOMETIMES PROJECTING OUT SOME
OF THAT WORK PARTICULARLY WITH
STATE EMERGING CONTAMINANTS
LIKE G. FAST- BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL NOT SURE ABOUT WHAT THE
COST YOU KNOW THE COSTS VARY
FROM A HUNDRED THOUSAND TO
MILLIONS. PER SITE AND THEN YOU
KNOW THE SCALE AND SCOPE OF A
CONTAMINATION IS ALWAYS VERY
PROJECT SPECIFIC SO IT'S A
LITTLE HARD TO SORT OF FORECAST
OUT WHAT THE RESOURCE IS
EXACTLY WILL GET US BUT I THINK
WE CAN GET SOME SENSE AT LEAST
AND AT LEAST THROUGH HINDSIGHT
FROM WHAT WE'VE ENCOUNTERED
PREVIOUSLY. YOU KNOW I WILL I
WILL ACKNOWLEDGE WHEN IT COMES
TO P. FACET IS STILL AN
EMERGING CONTAMINANT CONCERNED
BUT WE'VE TAKEN REAL FACED A
REAL PHASED APPROACH AND-
TRYING O ON EARTH WHERE PEOPLE
ASK CONTAMINATION IS REALLY
STARTING WITH THE MOST OBVIOUS
SITES LIKE AIRPORTS. AND
FIREFIGHTING- AREAS WHERE
FIREFIGHTING FOAM WERE USED-
WHICH WE KNOW HOW TO CONTAIN
HIGH AMOUNTS OF LUCKY FAST BUT
ALSO WITH PRO PLAYERS AND NOW
MOVING ON TO WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS- AND BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND IMPLEMENT AND
EFFLUENT CONCENTRATIONS OF THE
FASTER KNOWING THAT. ARE THERE
IS SO MUCH YOU KNOW IN OUR
CLOTHES AND STILL IN MODERN-
GARMENTS THAT- MAY BE A SOURCE
AND SO AGAIN THE COST THERE THE
TIME AND- IT'S STILL AT WORST
OFF THE FOREFRONT OF THAT SO-
SCOPING IT OUT- WHAT WE'LL DO
OUR BEST. AND AGAIN- THE
RESPONSE TO AND YES I ON. WHEN
IT COMES TO RISK. PARTY IT IS
ALWAYS SO. TO ENSURE WE IMPORT.
GET TO AND FINE AND KEEP. WE'RE
PARTIES FOR. THE DEGRADATION
THAT THEY'VE CREATED IN THE
HARM TO BENEFICIAL USES OF
OTHER OTHER USERS INCLUDING
MOST IMPORTANTLY DRINKING WATER
FOR ALL OF US- YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT BARED ON RATE PAYERS IS NOT
BARED ON. ON THE STATE BUT
INSTEAD THOSE WHO. OPERATED THE
CONTAMINATION TO BEGIN WITH-
SO. YES AS A- COMPLETE
PRINCIPLE THAT'S ALWAYS
ADJACENT WOULD BE FAST. I'VE
SEEN SOME REALLY ACTION I THINK
FROM FROM SOME WATER DISTRICTS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THIS
POINT- NATIONALLY AS WELL I
KNOW SOME STATES HAVE.
UNDERTAKEN WORK. AND I KNOW. WE
CONTINUE TO. HAVE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND. GREAT AT THE YOU AND
THE- OTHER MISTER SMITH YOU
JUST YOURSELF- IN REGARDS TO
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE- IS A-
RECOVERABLE. FURTHER
DISCHARGERS AND WHY DO WE HAVE
A BACKLOG. AND IS IT MORE THAN
A YEAR OLD A BACKLOG ARE WE
GOING ALL THE WAY BACK. TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
WITH WITH THE- I THINK ON THE
SITE YEAH I THINK IT DEPENDS ON
THE SITE- YOU KNOW SOMETIMES A
BACKLOG BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
MOST SORT FORTY ESTá AMONGST-
THE CHALLENGES OR THE CLEANUP
SITES THAT THERE ARE- AND YOU
KNOW WE AND I'LL SAY THAT YES I
WHILE IT'S- MOSTLY FULLY
RECOVERABLE IN SOME CASES IT'S-
IT'S NEEDING TO BE POP ROCK
REPORTS BUT ACTION AND- YOU
KNOW IT TAKES A LITTLE LONGER
TO. DECIDE BRING TO OUR
POLLUTION WHEN IT COMES TO THE
RECOVERY OF THE FUNDING- YOU
KNOW THE AGAIN THE BACKLOG IS
THERE BECAUSE YOU NEED THE
ACTUAL BODIES. TO PROCESS THE
PROJECTS YOU TO REVIEW THE
PLANS AND TO ACTUALLY GO AFTER
AND ENSURE THAT THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES ARE ARE UNDERTAKING THE
WORK AND THE PROJECT IS A
VIABLE ONE BECAUSE IT'S ONE
THAT'S IN THE PROGRAM. IT'S
BEING MONITORED WE'RE SEEING
THE COST PER ROUTE YOU KNOW
GETTING REIMBURSED ON THAT WERE
BILLING- AND SO IT'S KIND OF
THAT THAT THAT YOU KNOW THAT
NEED FOR JUST THE CORE- IF YOU
WILL BODIES TO ACTUALLY
PROCESS. THAT WORK THAT ALLOWS
US TO RECOVER MORE IF YOU WILL-
SO THE BACKLOG IS SOMETHING
ABOUT YOU KNOW AGAIN IT'S
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY TO ME
SEVENTY FIVE STAFF IT SOLELY
BEEN DOING WHAT IS I GET UP. AT
THIS AT THIS POINT AN OPEN CASE
LOAD OF FOUR THOUSAND- WHICH
AGAIN THEY'RE THEY'RE YOU KNOW
THEY'RE BOTH KIND OF FOCUS HAVE
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED TO A TIME.
IN AND USE OF SUBCONTRACTORS
INITIALLY FOR THE SOIL TESTINGS
AND ALL THAT. OR DO WE'VE EVER
TO DO EVERYTHING IN HOUSE. NOW
EVERYTHING IS. THROUGH SO THE
RICH. PARTIES WILL SUB. AND IS
WHAT WE- WE'RE OVERSEEING IN
AND THE PROBE. IS OKAY
HORIGUCHI VENDOR YOU KNOW THAT
THE AND AS I UNDERSTANDING
CARAMEL THIS IS ON HERE. SHE
CAN GET SHE SAT AT A PROGRAM
LEADING CAN GIVE. MAKE SURE I'M
NOT GOING TO STRAIGHT HERE. BUT
AS I UNDERSTAND IT IT IS- YOU
KNOW YES IT IS A LOT OF
SUBCONTRACTORS THAT END UP
DOING THIS WORK. AND THEY'RE
PAID. AND OR YOU KNOW- PAGE
THROUGH AGAIN THE FUNDS AND OR
REIMBURSE DIRECTLY FROM. THAT
YEAR- THE SITE CLEAN UP-
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES. IN JUST A
COUPLE TO GET WITH THE CHAIR A
LITTLE BIT LATER IN REGARDS TO
THE BATTERY CITI'S IN LA THIS
BEEN AND ALL OVER THE NEWS.
WOULD LIKE TO GET SOME UPDATE
ON THAT IS A GOES THROUGH
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THEY'RE
GOING TO. FILE BANKRUPTCY. AND
THEN THE TAXPAYERS A CALIFORNIA
WILL HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT THE
CLEAN UP SITE. YES DOT BALL ALL
NOTE THAT CLEAN UP SITES ARE
DIVIDED BETWEEN OURSELVES WE
HAVE- PARTICULAR FOR THE NEXT.
WITH BONDED SURFACE WATER AND
GROUNDWATER AND REQUIRE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE. ARE THERE
UNDER OUR SUCH. ON SITE
CLEANUP- PROGRAM IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SOMETHING
CONTROL HAS THEIR OWN SITE
CLEANUP- PROGRAM AN ACCOUNT AS
WELL. AND I BELIEVE OUR OR THE
LEAD FOR THE EXPECTING UP BUT-
I'M SURE THERE THERE IS- SOME
SOME NEXUS WITH US AND SO WE
CAN. STILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
YEAH. COMMUNICATED ANSWER
CANADA JOHN. HUSING YOU'RE A
FROM OUR- DIVISION OF FINANCE-
ART. MEASUREMENT THE MYSTERY
SERVICES OR BUDGET. CAN I
RESPOND. WE WILL HAVE DETAILS
SEE HERE AT A FUTURE MEETING
I'M NOT SURE WHICH ONE IT IS
BUT- THAT'S- ALWAYS A- THE-
EXCITE- BATTERY PLANT CLEANUP
IS ALWAYS A LIVELY TOPIC OF
FOR. A CONVERSATION THAT-
ACTION RIGHT LITTLE LESS THIS
YEAR. THANK YOU IT'S A
CHALLENGING PROJECT. FOR
CERTAIN. VISIT THANK YOU
GOODBYE COUPLE YEARS AS I SEE
TO CALM IN A BOARD SO I THINK
WHEN YOU GOT A- I. YOU LATER
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THAT BRINGS US TO THE CLOSE OF
OUR FORMAL PRESENTATIONS WILL
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT LET
ME REMIND THE FOLKS WHO MAY
WANT TO CALL AND THE FULL FREE
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. AND IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CALL THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099 IS
THERE ANYONE- IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GET PUBLIC
COMMENT I SEE IT TWO PEOPLE
PROBABLY- PLEASE STEP FORWARD
AND- GOSH DARN IT DON'T TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR BILL AND IF YOU COULD KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS AT ALL PUBLIC
COMMENT- TO APPROXIMATELY ONE
MINUTE YOU'RE APPRECIATED. YOU
CHAIR BLOOM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I'M DANNY MERKLEY
DIRECTOR WATER RESOURCES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU- I'M
HERE TO- GIVE OUR SUPPORT TO
THE CAT- CALIFORNIA TO
RESOURCES AGENCIES PROP. SIXTY
EIGHT HABITAT IMPROVEMENT BCP
THAT ISSUE ONE- WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT EARLY
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIONS.
PROPOSED BY THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS- CAN BE FUNDED. AND
IF I MAY JUST VERY BRIEFLY ON-
ISSUE FOR REGARDING SIGMA.
WANTED TO- MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ALL KNEW- WHAT A GOOD JOB. OF
THE DEPARTMENT HAS DONE IT OUT
OF REACH TO ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AGRICULTURE NGOS-
TRIBAL CONCERTS IN AND EVERYONE
INVOLVED. IN UNDER- CHARMS
LEADERSHIP- SHE'S NOW GONE AND
THEN STEVEN- TAKEN OVER- AT
LEAST ACTING TEMPORARILY-
THEY'VE DONE A VERY GOOD JOB AT
OUTREACH AND INCLUSION WITH
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS. AND.
LASTLY JUST OF. PHOTO LAB JUST
A EVER QUICK OF EARLY. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS WHOSE BIRTHDAY IS
SATURDAY. TWENTY I FOUND WITH
AN ADVOCATE I'M SORRY. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MARK SMITH'S
POLICY GROUP HERE ON BEHALF OF
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT CLIENTS
WANT TO TOUCH ON THREE
DIFFERENT ITEMS- FIRST HELLO TO
THE NEW MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THIS YEAR ON
THE NON PRESENTATION CALENDAR
THE COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WHO
WERE THE SPONSORS OF AB
NINETEEN FORTY NINE BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BANNER ABOUT
THE SUPPORT THAT ISSUE MOVING
FORWARD AND ARE GLAD TO SEE THE
DEPARTMENT MAKING THAT
INVESTMENT IN OUR STATE'S ONLY
MARINE HATCHERY PROGRAM WHEN I
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT THE ONE
TIME FUNDING THAT DIRECTOR
BOTTOM TALKED ABOUT
PARTICULARLY THE INVESTMENTS IN
WETLANDS AND LICENSING
MODERNIZATION I REPRESENT
HUNTING AND ANGLING COMMUNITIES
I'D LIKE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
LICENSES AS A PRODUCT THA IS
SOLD. IN A STORE FOR EXAMPLE
AND EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE THOSE
PRODUCTS HAVE TO BE REFRESHED
IN ORDER TO GET THE PUBLIC TO
CONTINUE BUYING THEM WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH ELECTRONIC
LICENSE AS WE NEED TO OFFER
ALTERNATIVES LIKE A THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE DAY
ANNUAL FISHING LICENSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT IS GOING TO CARRY
THAT BILLAGAIN THIS YEAR. THE
PRODUCTS OF THE DEPARTMENT
CELLS WHICH GENERATE THEM A LOT
OF REVENUE NEED TO BE IMPROVED
AND ENHANCE FROM TIME TO TIME
SO WE SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S
INTEREST IN INVESTING IN
UPGRADING ITS LICENSING SYSTEM.
I'D LIKE TO CLOSE BY TALKING
ABOUT SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
MYSELF AND OTHERS WHO WILL TALK
ON THE PHONE LIKE KIM DELFINO
JENNIFER FEARING AND MANY
OTHERS HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS CONVERSATION OVER THE LAST
DECADE WE KNOW THERE IS A
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
WE DIDN'T NEED A STUDY TO TELL
US THAT. THE SERVER SPACE
BUDGETING LAYS IT OUT CLEARLY
AND IDENTIFIES THE GAPS. MORE
EXPLICITLY THAN WE'VE EVER SEEN
BEFORE BUT A TEN MINUTE
CONVERSATION IN THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY. IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO
DIVE INTO SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE INVESTED MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT SPENT TWO YEARS
WORKING ON. I REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES LIKE HUNTERS AND
ANGLERS WHO ARE WILLING TO
RAISE FEES ON THEMSELVES AND
THIS YEAR. MISS AGUILAR CURRY
HAS A BILL THAT WILL DO EXACTLY
THAT TO FUNDED PROGRAMS AT THE
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
BUT WE OURSELVES CANNOT CLOSE
THIS GAP. THESE ARE PUBLIC
TRUST VALUES LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
BIODIVERSITY WHICH MANY OF US
SUPPORT. WE NEED GENERAL FUND
MONEY WE NEED MORE CONSISTENT
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
MEET. ITS SERVICES AND THE
THINGS THAT IT PROVIDES TO ALL
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA NOT
JUST HUNTERS AND ANGLERS SO. I
WOULD URGE YOU TO HOLD A
SPECIAL HEARING ON SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING TAKE MORE TIME
TO TALK ABOUT IT- THE
LEGISLATURE MANDATED THIS
PROCESS THEY SHOULD GET A FULL
AND THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF IT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT IT SHOULD
BE PUBLICLY DISCUSSED. AND I
APPLAUD YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
TODAY MISTER CHAIR WE NEED
SOLUTIONS ON THE TABLE I DON'T
WANT TO BE HERE TEN YEARS FROM
NOW HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
WITH THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
FOLLOWING AFTER YOU. LIKE WE
WERE HERE TEN YEARS PREVIOUSLY
BEFORE YOU ARRIVED THIS PROBLEM
NEEDS TO BE SOLVED NOW IS THE
TIME THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO TAKE ADDITIONAL TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- AND- WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO. FOLKS WHO ARE
CALLING IN AND I THINK
SOMEWHERE OUT IN THE ETHER
THERE'S AN OPERATOR. WHO WILL
BE FACILITATING- SILVA. THOSE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OUT LADY GERMAN THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NAY T. T.
OPERATOR OF WHICH YOU ARE
APPLYING REAL QUICK AND GIVE
YOU A LINE NUMBER SO YOU CAN
ASK YOUR QUESTION. AGAIN FOR
OUR- PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE THE
FIRST ONE MISTER CHAIR YES
PLEASE. OKAY WE WILL LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
AND WE HAVE TO BE YEAH. THE NEW
YORK YOU ARE OPEN GO AHEAD.
OKAY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ADAM KEENEST ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES. I
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
ITEMS I DID ONE OF THE WAITED
TO FUNDING FOR VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS. OF COURSE WRONG
WITH THE SB A PROCESS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS WITH THE BEST
APPROACH TO ACHIEVING. THAT
GOALS OF PROTECTING RESTORING
AND ENHANCING. I DOUBT THAT
BECAUSE SYSTEM AND INCREASING
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AT THE
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES THAT ARE
OPERATIVE IN THE BEATINGS ARE
READY TO BEGIN THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND HAVE
PLEDGED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF AN EXTENSIVE SERIES
OF RESTORATION PROJECTS TO
ENHANCE. FISH AND WILDLIFE
HABITAT. WHAT'S FUNDING IN ITEM
ONE IS REALLY ESSENTIAL TO
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE GOODS. I AM VERY QUICKLY
ONE EXPRESSED SUPPORT REGARDING
REGARDING ITEM FOUR- ARTICLE
CONTINUES TO ADVOCATE THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO ENSURE THAT FUNDING IS
DEDICATED TO SUCCESSFUL SEGMENT
IMPLEMENTATION- INCLUDING THE
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS REQUESTED
TODAY. BY THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT D. W. ARE
IN THEIR IMPLEMENTATION ROLE
SICK AND THE GSA THE BASIC TO
IMPLEMENT THEIR- SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS. I AT DIRECTOR MISSTATE
IT TO REALLY POOR TO GET THIS
FUNDING OUT SOON SO WE SUPPORT
SPLIT FUNDING. THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT HEARING
THEM THIRTY MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN NOT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU DO A LAKE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
ONE ZERO AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY EIGHT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCIES
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT HABITAT
GROUPEMENT PTP BUT THIS YOU
NUMBER ONE YOUR AGENDA. THE
UNDER TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR OPERATIONAL FUND PRODUCT
UP STORE NATURAL AQUATIC
FUNCTIONS WETLAND HABITAT FOR
BIRDS AND AQUATIC SPECIES.
RESTORATION ENDANGERED SPECIES
AND HENCE THE LIABILITY WATER
SUPPLIES AND PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE ECONOMIC BENEFIT. AS
ENVISIONED BY PROP SIXTY EIGHT
THIS FUNDING WILL HELP ADVANCE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
COLLABORATIVE ADAPTIVE AND FIND
FAITH APPROACH JUST WATER
MANAGEMENT THAT'LL HELP PROTECT
RESTORE AND CAN'T YOU GOT THAT
THE- OTHER GREATER BATTLE TO
WATERSHED AS WELL AS PROVIDE
MORE RELIABLE WATER SUPPLY FOR
CALIFORNIANS. HOMES FARMS AND
BUSINESSES. HOW WE SUPPORT A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS FOR PRODUCT
SELECTION TO ENSURE THE FUNDED
PROJECT ADD REAL VALUE TO IN A
TIMELY FASHION SENATE STEPS
DEPUTY SECRETARY NOTED THIS
MORNING OUT THERE ARE NO
REGRETS PROJECTS THAT ARE READY
TO GO. MANY OF THESE PRODUCTS
CAN ALSO ADDITIONAL LEVERAGE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AND LOCAL
FUNDING RESOURCES. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION THE
CALM WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
ADMINISTRATION THROBBING IT'S
IMPORTANT PROPOSAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
COMMENT. I NEXT WILL GO TO TWO
EIGHT GO AHEAD- MOVING ALONG
WITH A LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS GREG'S LOT NECK WITH THE SAN
JUAN WATER DISTRICT AND THAT WE
JUST WANT TO ADD OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE B. C. P. ON PROP SIXTY
EIGHT FOR THE- HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION. AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING THE RESOURCES
AGENCIES ABILITY TO UNDERTAKE A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS FOR PROJECT
SELECTION SO WE DON'T LOSE
VALUABLE TIME IN A LONG
COMPETITIVE PROCESS THERE ARE
NO REGRETS PROJECTS READY TO GO
AND- SO WE- DIDN'T LOSE JACK
SICKLY SUPPORT- THAT- EFFORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND NINE FORTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS LOOK AT FOR
EXAMPLE HAVE THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE SOME
PUBLIC COMMENT THIS MORNING
THERE'S A LOT TO SUPPORT ON
TODAY'S AGENDA BUT SPECIFICALLY
WANTED TO SPEAK TO ISSUE THREE
PERTAINING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGEMENT SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING ADVISORY COMMITTEE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS FOR THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT WE'RE
CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR SUPPOSED TO ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES TO MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARDS MULTIPLE MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING SUCH
SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA
BIODIVERSITY INCREASED ACCESS
OPPORTUNITIES AND INVESTMENTS
ARE STATE WILDLIFE. HOWEVER
THOUGH- IN LIGHT OF THE
RECENTLY COMPLETED SEPARATE
STATE BUDGET PROCESS IT'S ALSO
CLEAR THAT PLAN FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES CERTAINLY MORE THAN A
ONE TIME INVESTMENT IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE SIGNIFICANT STRUCTURAL
UNDERFUNDED GAPS IN THE MISSION
WORK OF DEPARTMENTS WHICH
WILDLIFE. MANY STAKEHOLDERS
FEEL STRONGLY THIS IS THE YEAR
TO PURSUE SOLUTION TO A LONG
TERM POSITION WHILE BY FUNDING
CHALLENGES WERE HOPEFUL THAT
THE SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
REPORT GENERATING MOMENTUM
AROUND THIS DECADES OLD PROBLEM
SINCE WE CLEARLY NOW HAVE THE
DATA AS TO WHAT IS AND ALSO
WHAT ISN'T BEING ADEQUATELY
FUNDED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR PATH LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE WE RECOGNIZE YOUR
FRUSTRATION REGARDING THE
SIGNIFICANT NEED HELP
APPRECIATE LEGISLATORS PASSED
THE POINT REGARDING THIS ISSUE
AND WE SUPPORT YOUR STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU AND SEE IF W. TO
CLOSE THE GAPS AND ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL CHALLENGES.
AND ONE FINAL NOTE WE ALSO
SUPPORT ISSUE FOR THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SEGMENT
PLANNING IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS
EITHER CENTRAL FOR SUCCESSFUL
SEGMENTATION THANKS. SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN PRESS ONE ZERO FOR.
PUBLIC COMMENT M. LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JIM MINOR ON BEHALF OF
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT- ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
EACH YOU WIND THE FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY. SIXTY EIGHT
HABITAT IMPROVEMENT WE ALIGN
OUR COMMON- WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM OFF WHY NOT BUT ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE VA'S AND-
PHYSICALLY FUNDING THAT YOU
KNOW MANY OF THESE HABITAT
RESTORATION PROJECTS ARE READY
TO GO AND CAN SUPPORT HABITAT
YOU KNOW THE VULNERABLE
ECOSYSTEMS IMMEDIATELY. WHICH
IS WHY THE CONCLUSION OF THE V.
EIGHT ARE SO IMPORTANT RIGHT
NOW- SO WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND. STRONGLY SUPPORT
ISSUE ONE. I YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS GAIL CALLING WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE TOO WOULD LIKE TO ECHO OUR
SUPPORT FOR PROPOSITION EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT. HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS I BELIEVE THAT I AM
ONE AND ALSO FOR ITEM FOR- THE
MONEY FOR MY IMPLEMENTATION
WHICH IS ALSO A CRITICAL EFFORT
ON BEHALF OF FARMERS SO- WE'D
LIKE TO LINE OUR COMMENTS TODAY
WITH NOT GOING OFF WELL IN THE-
EITHER WATER. DISTRICTS THAT
ARE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ITEM TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR
NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THAT JENNIFER FEARING OUT HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN
LION FOUNDATION AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME WARDENS
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION. AN OUTLINE
FOUNDATION STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE PROPOSED ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS HUMAN
WILDLIFE CONFLICTS THIS FUNDING
GIVES THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK MORE CLOSELY WITH
RESEARCHERS RANCHERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS TO
DETERMINE AND IMPLEMENT BEST
PRACTICES THAT WOULD PROTECT
PEOPLE WILDLIFE AND DOMESTIC
ANIMALS. AND THE GAME WARDEN
SUPPORT THE INVESTMENTS ON
PROPOSED FOR AIRCRAFT IN
OFFSHORE PATROL VESSELS TO
ENHANCE ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS.
BUT BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE
AMONG THE DOZENS OF DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE
COMMUNICATED TO YOU AND TO THE
ADMINISTRATION OUR DEEP CONCERN
THAT ALIGN WITH YOURS AND THE
L. A. ELLIS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
STRONG LEADERSHIP MR BLOOM AND
A LONG TERM COMMITMENT THAT
YOU'VE MADE INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATURE ADDING IN SHORT THE
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN THE S. B. B. EFFORT WHICH
BRINGS US TO THIS UNIQUE
MOMENT. AND YESTERDAY AND HAD
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PRIORITY THE
DRAFT THEM SECRTARY KOBACH
CONVEYED A COMMITMENT TO WORK
DAY HERE ON A LONG TERM FUNDING
SOLUTION AND WE WHO HAVE BEEN
AT THIS FOR YEARS ARE CERTAINLY
READY TO SEIZE THIS MOMENT TO
ADDRESS THE DECADES OLD FAILURE
TO KEEP PACE WITH THE SUPPORT
NEEDED TO LIVE UP TO OUR SHARED
NEED. TO ADEQUATELY PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S RICH BIODIVERSITY
WHICH IS UNDER PRESSURE LIKE
NEVER BEFORE THANK YOU WE LOOK.
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL ALLOW
THIRTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CATHY
FREEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND WE'RE HERE TO
CLASS SUPPORT FOR TWO ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. ITEM FOR THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT. THE FACT SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S APPROVAL FOR ONE
HUNDRED OPEN ALLOCATION OF
SIXTY MILLION FOR THE FUTURE
AFTER THAT BUT MY GRANT. COUNTY
ARE YOUR NEED FOR LAND USE
PLANNING AND SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR FUNDING UNDER THIS PROGRAM
AND WE WANT TO ALSO SUPPORT YOU
HAVE YOUR AFFECTS ONE FIFTH NOT
REACHED. ESPECIALLY FOR MEMBER
COUNTY WHICH THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING. ITEM FIVE BUT BUT
MANAGEMENT THE STOCK HAS A
POSITION OF SUPPORT FOR STATE
WIDE MULTI LEVEL FUNDING.
APPROACHES FOR NEW **** THE
TEXAN PROJECT. AS WE HAVE SEEN
WITH INCREASINGLY SEVERE
WEATHER EVENTS FLOOD MANAGEMENT
ABOUT THE CURRENT AND EMERGING
ISSUE. IN CALIFORNIA'S
RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO SO WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
PROPOSAL AND- WE WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THE OUT OF CONCERN
ABOUT THE BRIEF OF. FOLLOWING
WILDFIRES ONLY MAKES THE
FUNDING MARKED URGENT THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. AND NICK
BOTH LINE FOR. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING CARE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER CARE GENERAL FOR THE
STATE WATER. THE REPRESENT
TWENTY SEVEN PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES TO RECEIVE WATER FROM
THE STATE WATER PROJECT MY
COMMENTS ARE FOCUSED ON SUPPORT
FOR ISSUE ONE IN OUR LINE WITH
THOSE OF OCWEN OCWEN OTHERS
BEFORE ME- WE ARE WORKING ON A
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT- THERE WAS
A LETTER SIGNED BY MANY MANY
WATER USERS- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
FUNDING. WE ALSO SUPPORT A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS WE THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT- MANY
PROJECTS ARE READY TO GO AS
WITH NOTED- BY AND IT'S NORRIS
AND THERE'S A LOT OF NO REGRETS
PROJECT. UNFORTUNATELY OUR
EXPERIENCE THAN THAT THE
COMPETITIVE PROCESS TAKES ABOUT
TWO YEARS OR MORE BY THE TIME
AND AGENCIES SOLICIT AND
ULTIMATELY AWARDS THE FUNDING
SO OUR CONCERN IS BY USING A
PROCESS THAT WAY WE'RE JUST
DELAYING THESE NO REGRETS
PROJECTS THAT. WE THINK WE CAN
FIND A WAY TO EVERYBODY ON THE
SAME PAGE IN A TRANSPARENT WAY
TO REALLY ACT BUT I GETTING
SOME OF THE THINGS ON THE
GROUND- THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING WE
HOPE THEY MOVE FORWARD QUICKLY-
AND IF SO THE FUNDING IS NEEDED
IT BUT EVEN IF THEY DON'T WE
DON'T WANT TO WAIT TWO YEARS TO
GET THESE NO REGRETS. PROJECT
IN THE GROUND SO- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MOTHER KIANA
RECKON VALLEY WATER FORMALLY
KNOWN AS SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT AND WE WANT TO
FIND BETTER SUPPORT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON ISSUE
ONE LETTER TO PROPOSITION SIXTY
EIGHT AND HAPPENING WITH THAT
THAT. WOULD BE ABLE CLASS ARE-
ARE VERY CRITICAL AND IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ROCESS PEOPLE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD CONTINUE
PUTTING POLITICS WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME WE ARE HEARING
TODAY ON JOB CORPS TO WORK WITH
YOU IN. THE FUTURE. THANK YOU.
AND LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI VALERIE MARATHON CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCE ASSOCIATION
EIGHTY P. BUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR HABITAT IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS WE HAVE BEEN IN
SUPPORT OF THE- VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT PROCESS. CONCEPTION
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS FUNDING
WILL HELP IMPROVE. THE SPEED AT
WHICH PERHAPS THESE AGREEMENTS
CAN GO FORWARD TO LOOK FORWARD
TO SPEAKING WITH YOU MORE IN
THE FUTURE ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. L. OVERLYING FORTY
SIX PLEASE CALL AT. HI GOOD
MORNING IT'S A STEEP WALK
APARTMENT VISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALGARY TOWER LIGHTS WE
ALSO WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU
RESPECTED ISSUE ONE ON THE TOP
SIXTY FUNDING TO TAKE IN
CONSIDERATION THE FUNDING NEEDS
FOR THE STATEWIDE OBLIGATIONS
IN PARTICULAR THE TAL COMPACT
AND BE- FUNDING NEEDS WITH
THAT. BARLINEK IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM I WOULD LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RETURN ON AVERAGE WILL
BE AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
COMPUTER CENTER AND I'M CALLING
FOR ITEMS OR WAITING TO PICK UP
SPEED WHILE WE STRONGLY THE
FUNNY THING AND CONDITION
THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED TO LET
HER ARE TO IT COMMUNITY WATER
RESULTING FROM THE INCOME OF
LOCAL BUDGETS. WE MUST PROPERLY
EQUIPPED AND SEGMENT TO ENSURE
THAT ALL BENEFICIAL USE ARE
TAKE INTO AND EACH THINK THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER IS
ESSENTIAL AND HAS GREAT OVERLAP
OUR STATE ABILITY TO LOOK AS
MENTIONED TODAY WE MUST ALSO
REVIEW THE STATUS OF THE-
DEGREE OF INTEGRITY AND SURE
SEGMENT IS NOT UNDERMINED THE
STATE'S GREAT WORK TO EXPAND
WATER ACT THAT AN INCREASE
WATER QUALITY. THANK YOU
CHAIRED BLOOM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT COMMITTEE STAFF AND
DIRECTOR NEWMAN FOR YOUR WORK
ON IT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE. WITH THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE LINE FORTY
ONE. GOOD MORNING THIS CHAIR
AND MEMBERS BUSINESS REBEL
MONSTER THAT NOT A WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND IT'S NICE
TO SEE- YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO WELCOME THE NEW MEMBERS
MISTER SMITH AND MISTER BENNETT
TO THE COMMITTEE- I JUST WANTED
TO JOIN THE CHORUS OF VOICES
THAT ARE. SUPPORTING AND- YOUR
REQUEST TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GO BACK FOR
A- TO RE EXAMINE LONG TERM
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE I TOO HAVE
BEEN AROUND HERE LONG ENOUGH TO
BE WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR
OVER TEN YEARS. AND AND WITH
ALL TO A PARK WITH THE PLAN AND
SECRETARY CROAK PUTS UP
PRESENTATION WHERE HE IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THAT
BOB SO I LINE MY COMMENTS WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
JENNIFER FEARING AND MARK
SMITH- AND STRONGLY SUPPORT-
SEIZING THE MOMENT TO ADDRESS
THE- EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE
ANOTHER ANOTHER DEPARTMENT THAT
HAPPENED AS. YOU SAID IT'S AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT MISSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LIKE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT'S A LOT
SO ON BEHALF OF THE CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT- HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
ONE THAT PROP SIXTY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR HABITAT
RESTORATION- WE ARE SUPPORTING
THE COMMENTS OF THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS AQUA AQUA AND
OTHERS- IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF
ITEM NUMBER ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY THERE
ARE OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BACKGROUND YEAH CALIFORNIA THAT
A CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE'RE GOING TO GET A
REGISTER OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
DON PREDICATION ITEM ITEM
FIFTEEN WHICH ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY FULL TIME POSITIONS UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. ARE THESE SEVEN
DEFINITELY HERE FOR QUITE SOME
TIME IT WILL BE CRUCIAL TO
ENSURE INCREASED MAINTENANCE
REPAIR AND REPLACEMENT OF THE
STATE EIGHTY WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BECAUSE OF
THAT WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
QUICK CHARGER POLITICIZED AND
WHAT. ACTUALLY BOB. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BY THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN BRANDON DUCKWORTH
CALIFORNIA- I'M CYNICAL AND
TUITION PURSUE ONE OF OUR
ARTISTIC FUNDING OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF THE SPONSORING BY
THE FIRST COMPETITIVE PUBLICA
UP WE THINK THIS WOULD BE
NECESSARY. TO BEST PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY BUT ALSO THE
MAKING SURE THAT THE BEST
PROJECTS ARE SELECTED SO WE'RE
ASKING THAT YOU ALSO ESTABLISH
CLEAR CRITERIA FOR SELECTING
THE PROJECT. AND THAT YOU-
pCORP ANCESTRY AND WEBER JUST
AROUND THE STATE. STATUTE FOR-
AND THEN ALL ON- ISSUE THREE TO
GET UP- WE LIKE SEE- AT LEAST
SOME SORT OF ACTION TO BE
REPORTED- FROM DEPARTMENT TAKE
ADDRESS THE ISSUE BEFORE THEY-
BOB THIS IS AN APARTMENT HAS.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE THIRTY BY THIRTY
FIVE RECEIVE SHOULD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. A FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI ONE OF THEM ON THE
WITHOUT ONE CALIFORNIA- I WE
HAVE COMMENTS BOND FOR ITEMS
ITEM NUMBER ONE- WE AGREED THE
COMMENTS MADE BY- HEALTHCARE
CLUB- AND WE AGREED WITH THE L.
A. L. IN STAFF RECRIMINATION TO
ADOPT LANGUAGE ON A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM AND PARADISE
PROJECTS ACCORDINGLY. I DIDN'T
NUMBER TWO- B. L. T. F. FUNDING
PROPOSAL WE HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE USE OF THE LPF MONIES
FOR THESE PURPOSES AS OUTLINED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION- WE AGREE
WITH THE STAFF COMMENTS ON THE
USE OF THE MONIES- IF WE THINK
THAT THEY COULD LOOK AT. IT WE
COULD BE LOOKING AT THAT THE
SLIPPERY SLOPE COMPONENT OF OUR
NET FOR THE USE OF THE FUNDS-
AND THAT SHOULD BE EVALUATED
ACCORDINGLY HAN ITEM NUMBER
THREE WE ALIGNED OUR COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF. THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THE L. A.
OLD RECOMMENDATIONS AREN'T ON
THE ITEMS- WE HAVE A LIGHTNING
BY WITHOUT BIODIVERSITY CRISIS
AND WE NEED TO- THIS DEPARTMENT
BE ADEQUATELY FUNDED TO MEET ME
THAT MISSION- MISSION
OBJECTIVES AND I'M ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE PICK UP. THE
DEPARTMENT. OF WATER RESOURCES.
WE WANT A FEW IT THAT'S ALL-
COMMITTEE SHOULD IF THEY MY HOW-
WE LIKE TO SEE MORE DO ON HOW
TO DO. PLANS TO OF THIS- LIKE I
SAID. ARE WE LAST JULY FIFTY
FIVE. SORRY ABOUT THAT YOU READ
A LITTLE BIT OVER ON YOUR TIME-
HOPEFULLY YOU'VE GOT ALL THE
POINTS AND- THAT YOU'RE
INTENDING TO MAKE WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. WE WILL GO TO
LINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS OF HIS GROUP OF
EMBARRASSMENT SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER ACTION
LIKE TO COMMENT ON ITEM FOR-
MEMBERSHIP BIG MAMA WE ARE FOR
THIS ITEM INDIVIDUALLY- BUT
ACTUALLY I WOULD LIKE THEM FIVE
ECHO COMMENTS MADE BY FAMILY
MEMBERS BE BENNETT AND OTHER
COMMENTERS ON THE BOARDS OF.
THE W. ARE VOLATILE BITING
GUIDANCE IS VERY CONCERNED OUT
OF THE ATTIC WITH YOUR FRIENDS
WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
DETAILS- IN THE STEP THAT WILL
BE TAKEN IN THE GST REVIEW
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
PLANS ARE ADEQUATE- AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING. ON
THIS ISSUE WITH YOU LAST YEAR
WE ASKED THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AS WELL TO HOLD THE- US
DEPARTMENT OF WATER BECAUSE OF
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ENSURING THAT
THAT GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS PROTECT THE HUMAN RIGHTS
WATER AND- WE'RE JUST FURTHER
YOU KNOW ECHOING THAT AND WE
WANT TO FEED THAT COMMITMENT BE
FOLLOWED THROUGH- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MUCH. AND
IT'S IRVINE PLEASE TRY ONE. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WE WILL GO TO ONE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KIM DELFINO AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE- PACIFIC PORTS TRUST
THAT'S APT TO BE ASSOCIATED
WITH OUR COMMENTS. TODAY AFTER
ITEM NUMBER THREE WE AGREED AT
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND MONEY AND
THAT YOU GET THAT THESE. BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL ARE DIRECTED AT
IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES
PARTICULARLY THE HUMAN WILDLIFE
CONFLICT APPOINTMENT. WETLAND
CONSERVATION OF VEGETATION
MAPPING. UP BUT WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS REQUIRE
CDFW TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BEFORE THE MAY
REVISION BUT SPECIFIC ACTIONS
TO ADDRESS THE SEVERE
SHORTFALL. IN THE DEPARTMENT'S
CAPACITY PARTICULARLY TO
HABITAT AND SPECIES
CONSERVATION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW AND PERMITTING. ENERGY
CHAIRMAN BLOOM CORRECTLY IT
POINTED OUT THE- IT
MINISTRATIONS CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL. HAS FAILED TO
IDENTIFY HOW TO ADDRESS THE-
SERVICE GAPS- THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY WE SHOULD NOT WAIT.
AND IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT YET
THESE- FINALLY I WOULD. TAKE A
SECTION WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE CHARACTERIZATION OF
THE INCREASE LAST YEAR TWENTY
FOUR MILLION OF GENERAL FUND IS
ADDRESSING THE EFF EACH SERVICE
SHORTFALL. THAT MONEY WAS IN
DROUGHT ADDRESS THAT ARE
INTENDED TO ADDRESS THE
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE IN THE
PRESERVATION FUND. AND TO AVOID
FURTHER REDUCTIONS AND EXISTING
SERVICE LEVELS. FOR ITEM NUMBER
ONE DEFENDER SUPPORT- THE L. A.
O. AND BUDGET STOPPED
RECOMMENDATION TO ADD BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE THE REPORT STATED
BAKER. HOW TO PRIORITIZE THE
USE OF A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IMPROPER. SIXTY AT PROP
FIFTY EIGHT HABITAT I THINK AND
I AGAIN REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN PLAN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON ALL THESE ISSUES
THAT THE NOTED BY PREVIOUS
CONCERT. WITH RESPECT IF HE IF
W. SHORTFALL BEEN. TEN YEARS IN
THE MAKING AND WE REALLY HATE
TO SEE THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK
I RIGHT NOW THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL GO LINE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
BLOOMING MA'AM ARE BACK MARKET
REPRESENT AMERICAN FARMLAND AND
CAL CLIMATE AFRICA NETWORK
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE.
SIXTY MILLION AND ONE GENERAL
IN THE OF WATER RESOURCES FOR
GRANTS THAT SUPPORT WHAT
PLANNING IN INCOME OF. THE
CROSS CREEK OVERDRAFT BASIN WE
URGE THAT YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ENSURE THAT A
PORTION OF THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR GRANTS TO
TECHNICAL ADVISERS TO ASSIST
LANDOWNERS LANDOWNERS AND
CREATING MANAGEMENT PLANS.
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING THE
IMPACTS TO AGRICULTURAL
PROPERTY DUE TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION EGGMAN WE THINK
THIS WILL GO A LONG WAY AND-
MITIGATING SOME OF THE IMPACT
THANK. YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
WHITE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHARE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I HOPE YOU
CAN HEAR ME IT IS READY
THOMPSON WITH THE METROPOLITAN
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR ITEM NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOUR FROM
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT FOR
HABITAT FUNDING METROPOLITAN
ALLIANCE THE COMMENTS WITH THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS ARE
QUITE ENOUGH WHAT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMANDA
MONACO WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WE WORK WITH AROUND THIRTY CAN
BE AS LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
AND EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY
I'M HERE TO- DIRECT MY COMMENTS
REGARDING. OR AND SEVEN AN
ISSUE FOR AND THAT SINGLE
GRANDMA MANAGE ACT THE OF WATER.
WE ECHO THE COME MADE BY CAN
WATER AND CLEAN WATER ACTION.
WELL WITH THE ROBUST FOR
CRITICAL GROUNDWATER ACT. AND I
THINK IMPORTANT TO COMMUNITY WE
WORK WITH WHO I THE NEXT DR
WELL WE WILL REQUEST THAT I
LEAST TEN OF THE FOR BEGIN
PROTECT SAYS GROW TO ENSURE
CONTINUED ENGAGE OF. CAN
ADVOCATE AND AT LEAST THIRTY
BUT OF THE FUNDING FOR PRO THAT
COULD CAN WATER AND INCLUDING
DRINKING WATER MEDICATION. FOR
I'M AS READY TO THE THINK AND
TO ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES AT
THE- AND THAT PICKING WATER
MEDICAID PROGRAM ARE IN-
DEPARTMENT ME REALLY URGE THAT
OF THE WATER. TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON GROUND WATER MARKET
AND ENSURE THAT DEMAND
MANAGEMENT DOESN'T HAVE TOO
LATE. SEVEN WE SUPPORT THE ITEM
BUT NOT THAT EARLY EVIDENCE IS
THAT. THE FUNDS ARE WIDESPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
EDITION OF FUNDING WILL LIKELY
BE NEEDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR FACILITATING CUT ALL
THOSE COMMENTS WE APPRECIATE
ALL THE PUBLIC COMMENT THAT WE
GET AND- THAT BRINGS US. TO THE
CONCLUSION OF OUR MEETING CAN I
GET TO SAY WE ARE ADJOURNED.